Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag.
Dir auch.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertvierunddreißig, wir schreiben den sechsten November zwanzig siebzehn und das heißt soviel wie wir sind jetzt sechs Jahre auf Sendung.
Und ein paar Zerquetschte.
Das ist doch spannend. Fünf äh der Geburtstag von Logbuch Netzpolitik ist irgendwann Ende Oktober. Wir hatten äh ja doch Ende Oktober, ne? Am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober ist der Jahrestag von und,
was mir einfällt, der fünfte November Remember Remember, ne? Haben wir die LMP zweihundert gemacht vor einem Jahr,
Das ist jetzt auch das Jahr eins nach NRW zweihundert und das Jahr sechs nach.
Dem achtundzwanzigsten zehnten zweitausendelf, wo wir begonnen haben äh gemeinsam zu Podcast. Nachdem äh du, glaube ich, wenn ich mich recht entsinne zum ersten Mal mit der Idee auf mich zugekommen warst beim,
CC Camp zweitausendelf.
Genau, wobei ich versucht habe, dir das auf dem Camp zu erzählen.
Nämlich nicht dazu gekommen, ne?
Ich habe mehrere Anläufe gemacht, aber da waren immer so betrunkene Menschen, die.
Ich weiß nicht, oh das war irgendwie so, dass dann irgendwann dieses Camp vorbei war und ich dachte irgendwie noch, ich hatte noch so in Erinnerung,
Der Pritzmann wollte irgendwas aber wir sind nie dazu gekommen, weil das irgendwie sich dann ähm immer nicht ergeben hat. Wir hatten mehrere Anläufe äh dann auch mal abends vorm Wohnwagen sitzen ähm erinnere ich mich.
Ja, ja, genau. Immer.
War dann auch was mit einer betrunkenen Person, die noch dazu kam.
War glaube ich immer die gleiche bedrohende Person.
Begleit.
Ja, das waren äh war schön. Ich habe ich traue mich gar nicht mehr in die erste Sendung reinzuhören, weil ich noch weiß, dass die, also die, er hat, glaube ich, noch einen ganz anderen ähm.
Noch einen ganz anderen Flow äh.
Ja, bestimmt.
Da war so, da haben wir State of the Union, haben wir das genannt,
dieser Name für eine Episode würde dann später auch nochmal von anderen aufgegriffen äh aber ähm ich glaube State of the Juni ist die erste Folge und ich war da unglaublich ähm.
Nervös sowieso klar und ähm bedacht niemandem auf die Fußfüße zu treten. Das habe ich im Laufe der Jahre dat ein bisschen abgelegt, glaube ich.
Bisschen.
Es stellen sich aber auch die Leute wirklich ein bisschen zu ungeschickt in den Weg mittlerweile. Ähm da ist es äh auch nicht so einfach.
Ja
Ähm ansonsten äh immer nach wie vor einfach eine eine tolle äh Sache, also auch interessant zu sehen, wie das äh wie diese Idee hier,
Gedien ist. Oh, also was da so,
keine Ahnung, ne? Also die eine oder andere Veranstaltung ja schon gemacht, ne? In Hunden, LMP hundert mit Ströbele,
LNP hundertfünfzig beim ähm beim Camp äh wieder.
Mhm,
überhaupt nicht die schlechteste Methode bei so einem Wochenpodcast immer so in fünfziger Schritten sich zumindest ein bisschen was einfallen zu lassen, weil das ja dann so knapp auf so ein, na ja, nicht ein Jahr aber so.
Bisschen mehr als ein Jahr fällt. Ich denk wir haben auf jeden Fall 'ne ganze Menge ganz Aufkleber würdiger Sendungstitel generiert bekommen.
Ist auch bald wieder ein Kongress, müsste mal jemand.
Auf jeden Fall nochmal nachlegen und ja wir haben,
im Vorfeld so ein bisschen überlegt, was kann man jetzt mehr sagen, als darauf hinzuweisen, ich meine so Geburtstage sind ja irgendwie auch, ne? Ich meine, irgendwo ist das letztlich egal, die eigentlichen Zyklen, die bilden sich anders ab. Trotzdem ist es immer so ein bisschen anders, auch mal so ein bisschen zurückzublättern. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch so ein paar Sachen
die wir auch so noch nie gesagt haben,
ne? Vieles äh geschieht immer so ein bisschen im Verborgenen und wird dann blumig äh umschrieben äh zum Beispiel warst du sehr oft.
Gar nicht hier und ziemlich weit weg, ohne dass man das irgendwie groß äh gemerkt hat äh dank hervorragender Aufnahme äh äh Techniken auf beiden Seiten. Also was äh eine ganze Menge Kilometer äh abgerissen in der Zeit.
Ja, ich habe ähm,
Also das ist das tatsächlich ein Tim und ich haben uns da äh über Jahre einen einen Spaß draus gemacht, das einfach nie zu sagen, dass ich gar nicht da bin. Ähm ich war ähm ich, also ich habe jetzt gerade mal geguckt, also ich war mal in Abu Dhabi, Tel Aviv
New York, Mumbai, Mumbai, regelmäßig ähm,
da haben wir glaube ich größere Teil der Sendung war ich in Mumbai überhaupt und wir haben dann.
War ja so ein ganzes halbes Jahr, wo du fast eigentlich nur noch.
Zwei Jahre waren das echt? Oh wow.
Ähm aber das war äh der der also der wir haben's nie gesagt in den Sendungen und es hat ist auch glaube ich, dass es einfach nie jemandem aufgefallen hat aber diese äh wenn man an verschiedenen Orten ist äh,
Das war deshalb blöd wegen der Zeitunterschiede. Ähm es war nämlich zum Beispiel
also die die Indien Podcasts waren zum Beispiel für mich dann immer dreiundzwanzig Uhr
oder so oder zweiundzwanzig Uhr, wie wir die angefangen haben und dann ging das halt bis tief in die Nacht für mich und äh am nächsten Morgen musste dann wieder aufstehen. Ähm aber das war irgendwann haben wir äh hatte ich angefangen, das nicht zu erwähnen,
Und dann haben wir äh das auch weitergeführt und äh ich fand's eigentlich ganz lustig. Ähm,
Ja, das äh das war äh ganz alleine abends im Hotel sitzend und sich über die deutsche Politik unterhalten. War, war auch eine, war immer ganz interessant, ja.
Ähm und dann natürlich äh immer mal wieder auf Sendungen wo ich dann wirklich einfach mal nicht da war oder mal nicht wollte, viel mehr, das ist glaube ich eher das äh,
oder nicht ja manchmal manchmal kann man dann einfach nicht oder man sagt einfach so, nee komm die Woche ist echt voll genug, da muss ich mir jetzt nicht oder der die Zeit der Zeitunterschied ist ähm noch ungünstiger, sodass wir einfach nicht zusammenkommen,
hat er auch ähm bestimmte Zeitfenster des Tages nur und äh dann äh haben wir inzwischen auch echt ein,
wirklich coolen Stamm an anderen Sendungsgästen, die oder die jetzt in auch die man, ich glaube die sind inzwischen bei Logwochennetzkritik auch als Aufrut Unterteam gelistet, ne? Also Personen wie Andre oder Thomas.
Äh ja.
Als regelmäßige.
Falsches sagen.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher.
Also Andre und Thomas haben wir da auf jeden Fall aufgeführt und ich glaub das trifft's auch, weil die einfach so oft dabei waren. Ich schlage auch mal kurz nach. Also Thomas war jetzt insgesamt schon achtzehn Mal,
zu Gast, André vierzehn Mal,
Viermal hatten wir Kiri, viermal hatten wir Ruf Burmeier, dreimal Konstanze, dreimal Frank Rieger. Ja.
Thomas, der kriegt zu viel Exporte, ja, der wird jetzt mal hier kurz geschnitten. Nee, mit äh genau, das äh.
Na ja. Zurecht auf jeden Fall, ne? Also hat auf jeden Fall äh hier seine Ex-Porsche auch verdient.
Ey, ganz, ganz ohne Frage, aber äh gerade mit Thomas hatte ich auch vor einiger Zeit mal so einen Moment, dass wir auch mal zurückgeblickt haben, äh weil sich.
Also ähm auch für also für Thomas äh äh und auch für mich natürlich auch viele im Leben geändert hat in dieser, in dieser Zeit, ne? Also zweitausendelf ist echt lange her.
Wenn man so jung ist wie ich.
Nee, das ist in der Zeit ist viel passiert. So äh und ähm da haben sich ja viele.
Viele Dinge entwickelt ähm auch äh,
dann kann man sich auch mal trösten, dass du gerade mit Thomas kann man ja auch immer mal zurückblicken auf Erfolge. Thomas ist ja derjenige, der immer Erfolge feiert in Österreich.
Nicht nur in Österreich.
Und äh oder in der in der EU ähm,
und äh dann mal so zurückblicken auch äh was für mit was für Themen wir uns auseinandergesetzt haben. Vor vor sechs Jahren Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Staatstrojaner, also das waren Themen damals.
Rede ist heute keiner mehr da.
Kai, weißt du doch damals.
Netz sperren.
Ja. Nee, ist schön.
Du hast es übrigens auf zweihundertdreiundzwanzig Sendungen gebracht.
Okay, halt, also mein Fehlen ist dann doch häufig, ne? Ich bin auch gerade so ein bisschen über.
Zweihundertdreiundzwanzig von zweihundertdreiunddreißig heißt zehn Sendungen. Das ist nicht viel.
Ja, ja, stimmt. Ich klammer hier. Ich muss das hier verteidigen, ey.
Nicht dabei.
Offiziell nach offizieller Zählart, aber glaube ich nur eine. Ja, da war doch diese.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich war dabei, obwohl ich gar nicht dabei war. Das war auch merkwürdig.
Hm, ja, also eine macht irgendwie Freude und was ich ähm,
Was ich so feststelle im Gespräch mit äh regelmäßigen äh also mit Leuten, die die Sendung regelmäßig hören, die man immer bei einer Veranstaltung trifft oder so. Ähm.
Dass,
da werde ich die Frage, die ich am häufigsten gestellt kriege zu Logbuch Netzpolitik ist, wie schaffst du das eigentlich dabei gute Laune zu behalten,
und ich bin mal ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, ich schaffe das genau für die Dauer dieser Sendung.
Dann verfällst.
Und danach verfall ich in eine schwere äh Depression,
und ähm dann äh brauche ich eine Woche oder zwei und eine Clubmarte äh um,
oder zwei, um äh um hier wieder diesen Mut äh aufzubringen. Das ist auch nicht immer einfach. Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Natürlich ist das äh spielt das auch eine Rolle zu zu sagen, ja ähm,
jetzt musste mal kurz gucken, wie du da wieder in den lockeren Blick drauf findest vielleicht oder so.
Aber trotzdem und das mal aus dem Mund zu nehmen.
Es hilft halt einfach auch so eine regelmäßige Sendung zu machen, um sich dieser Themen auch selber auf eine andere Art und Weise zu vergegenwärt
ne? Also dieser Effekt, dass wenn man Dinge äh erklärt, selbst wenn man sie jetzt nicht bis ins letzte Detail erklärt äh denkt man dann doch,
auch anders darüber nach, von daher ist es ein ganz interessantes Training. Ja und was war noch ähm gut, gut fand ich vor allem so,
die Hyraschaft. Also ich bin ehrlich gesagt erstaunt,
dass die Nische äh so groß ist, die wir hier ähm adressiert bekommen.
Man kann jetzt über Zahlen immer streiten, so ich meine vor kurzem gab's da irgendwie so eine Umfrage mit was was sind so die wichtigsten Politikfelder in Deutschland? Was denken die Deutschen, was so wichtige Politikfelder sind? Jetzt Politik war da, glaube ich, auf Platz dreißig.
Echt? Migration auf Platz eins.
Ich habe jetzt leider, ich glaube.
Ja also äh ja genau Flüchtlinge Platz eins und dann halt so Arbeitslosigkeit halt die die üblichen Klassiker explodieren auf Platz dreißig. Ich hoffe ich finde auch noch den äh Link dazu. Ist jetzt bis dahin natürlich ein bisschen hören sagen, aber so habe ich's im Kopf.
Also, machen wir uns nichts vor,
Es ist nicht Talk of the Town. Ja, es gab da mal so dieses kurze äh Piratenhoch, wo alle dachten, Netzpolitik äh ja, das wird jetzt irgendwie so der Inbegriff und im Prinzip sind wir ja auch,
Das hat man glaube ich auch gemerkt in den letzten Jahren. Wenn wir uns hier über sowas wie diese G zwanzig Sache unterhalten, ne, wo dann ja auch gleich so äh in den Kommentaren die Debatte aufkam, äh redet doch mal lieber über euer Thema so. Und ich glaube.
Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen so ein auch von uns vielleicht auch durch den Titel äh allein auch schon mit verursachtes Missverständnis.
Okay, die Sendung heißt Lok Buchnetzpolitik. Jetzt kann man sich überlegen, was heißt das? Heißt das.
Wir reden nur über Themenfelder, die in irgendeiner Form des Internet betreffen, ja und und digitale Kommunikation oder heißt das,
Wir reden hier eigentlich über Politik und wir kommen aus dem Netz.
Ja also natürlich eher Letzteres.
Genau, natürlich eher letzteres so. Und wenn wir dann aber auf solche Ereignisse wie äh G zwanzig blicken, würde ich sagen, ja, das ist eine ganz normale
politische Debatte, die wir an der Stelle geführt haben und die wir auch wo auch versucht haben das Ereignis aufzuarbeiten durch äh das längere Gespräch und und und andere Nachrichten, die wir mit reingetragen haben
Aber wir schauen da halt einfach auch mit unserer netzaktivierten
Brille drauf. Das heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass wir da nur uns die digitalen Körnchen rausnehmen, weil da gab's jetzt erstmal gar nicht so viele. Sondern es ist halt eher eine Frage, was haben wir für ein Freiheitsverständnis,
was haben was wollen wir auch? Wie sich diese Gesellschaft wandelt oder,
vielleicht auch nicht wandelt an manchen Stellen und inwiefern drückt sich halt hier auch,
Ausdruck des Staates äh aus dem wir so nicht akzeptieren und der auch an anderen Stellen uns mit den urnetzpolitischen Themen Sorgen macht.
Bin also ähm so ein Kommentar, wie.
Machte, behandelt dieses Thema mal nicht, konzentriert euch auf was anderes. Äh der ist auf eine gewisse Weise ähm.
Den der tut nicht gut. Ähm also der ist kein Kommentar, den ich den ich äh der irgendwie spurlos an mir vorbeigeht. Ähm.
Aus.
Grunde, dass das so ein bisschen ähm der der klingt irgendwie so eine Verachtung auch raus, so, davon hast du Ahnung davon nicht,
davon steht da steht dir zu was zu sagen da nicht. Ähm und andererseits auch 'ne gewisse,
Anspruchshaltung gegenüber uns, die ich,
dann teilweise ein bisschen bedenklich finde. Erstens möchte ich darauf hinweisen ähm wir haben ein,
Wir haben Chapter Marx, wenn euch ein Thema nicht gefällt, könnt ihr immer weiterskippen. Ihr könnt auch Stopp drücken oder so. Ähm und ich nehme, gehe davon aus, dass wenn ihr so ein Feedback gebt, dass ihr das aber auch ernst meint und das nicht einfach nur daran liegt, dass euch äh,
irgendwas nicht, dass euch meine Meinung oder Tims Meinung oder die Meinung unserer Gäste nicht gefällt. Ähm.
Ich persönlich weiß aber auch, dass das ein, dass ich ein gewisses Maß in dieser Sendung auch haben will, wo sich wohl Menschen mit uns nicht übereinstimmen,
andere Meinungen haben, meinen Medienkonsum besteht größtenteils aus dem anderer Meinung, also,
Feindbeobachtung? Nein, aber einfach, also mir geht's um mir geht's um den ich will das gesamte Spektrum der Meinungen irgendwo sehen und wahrnehmen und ähm ich will auch, dass Lokbuchnetzpolitik,
ein Teil eure des Spektrums der des Publikums ist ja, wo man also sieht, ah okay, da ist auch nochmal, da habe ich einen interessanten Gedanken gehört und da stimme ich äh hier stimme ich nicht überein, ja? Ähm.
Interessante sowas wie.
So ein Kriterium der Objektivität oder so äh an uns äh zu tragen, finde ich dann auch teilweise sehr sehr interessant. Ähm,
Also ich glaube, wer diese Sendung irgendwie ein bisschen hört, hat glaube ich schon inzwischen rausgefunden, dass ich.
Sehr politisch bin und mich auch für noch viel mehr Politik interessiere, als wir hier bei Logbuchnetzpolitik behandeln. Ähm.
Und ab und zu ähm fühle ich mich ausreichend informiert zu einem Thema,
dass ich das auch hier mal dann ein Exkurs mache oder dass ich das Thema wichtig genug finde,
zum Beispiel diese G zwanzig äh Schiene da, dass man mal, dass man das auch mal hier
behandelt im Rahmen unserer politischen Bildungsmaßnahmen. In der Wahl äh diese G zwanzig Folge war finde ich nach wie vor eine der wichtigsten, die wir überhaupt gemacht haben.
Mhm. Denke ich auch.
Ja ähm ja, das ist so ein bisschen, was wir wir denken uns hier relativ viel bei und das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Aspekt, der glaube ich,
über den wir selten gesprochen haben in so einer Sendung steckt echt scheiße viel Arbeit.
Wir kommen da ja später nochmal zu, also diese die Vorbereitungen, dieser Sendung, allein dieser Medienkonsum es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass sich hier jedes Thema.
Wirklich voll durch äh also voll wichtig finde und aus Eigeninteresse unbedingt bis aufs letzte verstanden haben will,
Ja, also hier sind Themen dabei, die behandeln wir, weil wir weil das das Sendungskonzept ist, auch diese Themen vernünftig zu behandeln
und das sind nicht nur, dass ich irgendwie sitze und sage, ach hier ist also ein lustiger Blumenstrauß an, einen schönen, bunten Themen. Guck mal, hier habe ich auch noch eins, das da
da gefällt mir, das ist schön grün und das blüht im Frühling oder so und hier guck mal, hier habe ich noch ein Thema im Angebot, sondern die Themen werden halt von außen an uns herangetragen, die Themen geschehen, die prasseln auf uns ein und wir müssen dazu ähm.
Genau, liest du da mal die AGB von Stream on durch?
Ja, genau. Oder äh diese Staatstrianer Sache am Anfang des Jahres, ne, die da mich jetzt auch,
Hätte ich wäre was Schöneres vorstellen können als ähm als da diese ähm.
Also diese Stellungnahme zu schreiben, aber da sieht man nämlich nur einen anderen Aspekt, jetzt nicht eigentlich, dass wir.
Ja auch noch viel mehr und viel anderes machen als nur diese Sendung. Also,
was jetzt hier diesen politischen Kram angeht, ne? Also die regelmäßigen Stellungnahmen in Ausschüssen, die
sowas wie so ein Wahlhack, den Thorsten Martin und ich da mal gemacht haben. Das ist das Feld für mich auch irgendwie alles unter das, was,
Was was wir machen oder wo woran ich mitmache.
Politischer Arbeit.
Rahmen meines, ja genau politische meines kleinen Hobbys, dass ich jetzt hier irgendwie seit einiger Zeit fliege. Ja,
Tja, aber das äh so dass wir die Einblicke, genau und dann finde ich das, das ist dann echt immer sehr, sehr toll, wenn,
dafür auch mal ähm.
Wenn man dafür mal so ein Zeichen der Anerkennung bekommt. Also so äh bei einer Veranstaltung jemanden treffen, der dann sagt, ey, pass auf, ich höre das seit,
Folge eins und keine Folge ausgelassen und geiler Scheiß, danke, ne? So, das äh,
glaube ich, dass das bei den vielen bei den meisten Hörenden so sein wird, dass sie sich das aus dem Grund anhören, weil ihnen das Programm irgendwie gefällt. Gesagt kriegt man das selten. Und äh wenn also schon
oft genug, ja? Und das ist aber auch noch selten genug, dass auch jedes einzelne Mal,
wirkt, ja? Das ist äh noch nicht. Da gibt's noch keine Immunität, dass man irgendwie so sagt so, ja ich weiß, ist geil.
Und da kann ich dir auch sagen, als da ich das ja nun schon auch mit anderen Formaten und auch schon länger mache, dass dass hört auch nicht auf gut zu tun. Also es ist schon ja, ist.
Bin auch nicht abhängig davon, dass es jetzt permanent auf mich einprasselt und ich äh habe auch.
Erwarte auch jetzt keine besondere Rhythmik in den Einschlägen oder so, sondern ich freue mich besonders über Rückmeldungen, die so,
mit mit persönlichen Geschichten auch äh verbunden sind, ja? Ich will ja jetzt nicht zu weit ausholen, aber
Es gab schon in den letzten Jahren mehrere Male, wo ich so ein Feedback bekommen habe, was halt nicht nur so ich höre dich, sondern so potenziell eben auch. Und hätte ich das jetzt mal nicht gehört, dann wäre das und das und das in meinem Leben nicht passiert,
das wäre gar nicht so gut gewesen, wäre das nicht passiert wäre. So und das sind alles Sachen, von denen man sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein wenig ernähren kann.
Ja, das ist äh das ist ein, das ist ja, so diese Wirk so zu sehen, dass da irgendwie was, dass da was passiert so, ne? Das, dass da.
Also wenn ich äh daran denke, wie ich Podcast höre, ich habe ja ein total,
also ich höre am laufenden Bandpodcast, ich weiß es nicht. Für mich waren ja Podcasts irgendwann der Weg aus der Beschaffungskriminalität. Ich hatte mir so eine ich hatte mir so eine, ja, ist so. Ich hatte eine ähm,
Ich hatte mir über Jahre antrainiert, dass ich nur mit einem Hörspiel einschlafen kann.
Ich ähm und da irgendwie drei Fragezeichen, was da alles gibt, ne? Und ähm ich konnte ohne so ein Ding, ohne dass da irgendwie so ein Ding lief, nicht pennen.
Wann fing denn das an?
So keiner weiß nicht.
Reden wir jetzt schon von Kindesbeinen.
Nee, aber egal also ich äh.
Vermutlich, ihr ähm also dass ich irgendwann überhaupt erstmal genug hatte, da kam dann irgendwann mit Internet,
ne? Weil, wie gesagt, die, jetzt war das nicht so, also die drei Fragezeichen habe ich alle gekauft, ja, aber andere, nicht näher genannte. Ähm, habe ich halt äh äh aus, gab's im Internet,
Und äh dann habe ich irgendwann festgestellt, okay krass, es gibt irgendwie viel interessantere Angebote ähm.
Kostenlos.
Und ähm da da kam das dann, also der Weg aus der Beschaffungskriminalität, irgendwie so, also war auf jeden Fall echt eine lange Zeit. Ich würde schätzen, dass es irgendwann,
Neunundneunzig, zweitausend oder so angefangen hat. Mit der Sucht und dann irgendwann das dann eben weiter überging zu Podcasts.
Podcast. Dann hast du.
Und dann, da, da hat man nämlich, also nee, dann weiß man ja auch so, dass man wie,
Ja, was weiß ich, ne? Welche Stimmen einen da vielleicht auch wirklich dann inzwischen seit über zehn Jahren,
Begleiten, regelmäßig, die man sich regelmäßig anhört. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel, wann hast du angefangen mit äh CAE.
Zweitausendfünf.
Zweitausendfünf, ne? So würde ich da hätte ich das jetzt auch verortet. Ich war also ich weiß zufällig, dass ich die, dass ich das,
weiß ich gerade, wenn ich da eine Wohnung renoviert habe, äh wann und da weiß ich wann das war, da hatte ich die schon, da habe ich die schon alle gehört. Also da werde ich seit Anfang an dabei.
Aber das war so, also was ich meine ist, dass man zu seinen Podcastern, die baut man ja irgendwie so eine.
Irgendwie ein Verhältnis auf.
Das ist eine emotionale Brücke.
Das ist interessant oder es ist gar nicht so präsent dass ich selber vielleicht für einige Menschen auch so jemand bin der,
sie seit,
jetzt ein paar Jährchen auf irgendeine Weise jeden Abend mit mit schrecklichen Nachrichten, kleinen Horrorgeschichten aus Berlin.
In den Schlaf gruselt.
Das ist äh eine schöne Sache äh und äh da wollte ich dir auch mal einfach verdanken, Tim, dass du mir die Gelegenheit gegeben hast, dass äh diesen Weg in in meinem Leben auch irgendwie noch zu gehen.
Ja, gern geschieht, mir war das ja irgendwie ähm schnell klar.
So
Nicht am Anfang.
Ja, ich habe das so im im Gefühl gehabt, man da drückt mich mein Gefühl dann doch eher selten, so ich rieche das,
der ist nicht aufs Maul gefallen und äh er kann was. So und das sind so.
Mit dem Können, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, aber.
Ich habe an dich geglaubt, Linus. Ja und dann warst du da halt auch so.
Tja, das ist also so der, der Blick auf äh,
auf ein kleiner Blick auf auf das äh Logbuchum, wie wir es machen äh und äh ich bereue nichts äh Spaß gemacht und wird auch wird auch weiterhin Spaß machen,
und äh da äh machen wir machen wir weiter.
Genau, denken wir uns auch noch ein paar Sachen aus, wie es vielleicht noch lustiger werden kann.
Eine Sache habe ich mir ausgesucht, eine Sache habe ich mir ausgedacht. Darf ich das jetzt schon sagen, Tim?
Ja sicher.
Ja? Und zwar wollen wir mal was ausprobieren, was testen ähm,
Und zwar habe ich lange rum überlegt, wie man denn äh das,
so Feedback von von Zuhörern ähm,
besser in die Sendung einbringen kann und ähm dieses,
während sich äh gerade jetzt so was dieses ganze ultraschall und pottlove Ökosystem angeht,
unglaublich viele Entwicklungen in den letzten Jahren äh getan haben, ne? Also was äh mit Pott Love alles äh besser geworden ist, was reife, wahnsinnige geile Sachen gebaut hat mit dem Ultraschall-Team, um,
Podcasting, nieder, niederschwelliger zu machen, ja? Ähm begleitet von,
irgendwelchen Grandlern, den dann immer noch der Einklick zu viel ist, ne? Und die dann äh und dann gehen sie hin, gehen nach Hause und machen nur einen Klick weniger und äh da ist echt so viel geschehen
ja? Und Erik natürlich äh auch nochmal ganz besonders äh zu nennen und die vielen Leute, deren Namen ich jetzt gerade nicht nenne, bei denen entschuldige ich mich persönlich, aber das, was da aus dieser Community entstanden ist, ist echt irre. Äh und da ist viel,
viel Weiterentwicklung äh zu beobachten. Gerade hast du ja die neuen Pod Love Player äh ausgerollt auf den Meterebene. Publikationen, wenn nicht oder ist jetzt auch schon wieder ein Monat her oder so, ne?
Da ist halt jetzt die Alpha Version, habe ich halt irgendwann schon mal angeklickt, jetzt Release steht jetzt noch an in diesem Jahr.
Also da ist geiler, da ist geiler Scheiß. Und was ich nie so wirklich verändert hat, ist äh
die Art wie Feedback gesammelt wird, ja? Da, da, da, ist da sind zwar alle noch in den neunziger Jahren mit äh mit äh Freddit Comments so ungefähr, ja. Ähm,
und ähm die finden dann schwer ihren Weg zurück in die äh in die Sendung. Ähm.
Ich versuche ja immer mal wenn ich also Kommentare entweder die die Thesen zu subsumieren oder besondere Kommentare dann auch einfach mal vorzulesen. Aber ich hab mir überlegt was was ich gerne mal ausprobieren möchte,
ist Audiokommentare und ich hab lange darüber nachgedacht, dass das andere Sendungen auch schon versucht haben,
dann irgendwelche Apps oder sonst was, die man sich auf das Telefon installieren musste, genutzt haben und so. Alles nie so richtig geflogen. Und jetzt kann das sein, dass das einfach daran liegt, dass da,
Von den,
vom Publikum, von den Zuhörern gar nicht die Nachfrage besteht oder es liegt einfach daran, dass man sich irgendeine beknackte App äh mit irgendwelchen E-Mail-Registrierungen und so weiter runterladen muss oder so. Und deswegen habe ich überlegt, wir schalten jetzt einfach mal,
eine Hotline. Vierundzwanzig Stunden besetzt von einem Anrufbeantworter.
Ruf an.
Wo ihr ähm Audiofeedback äh zu der Sendung geben könnt mit der Einschränkung,
dass wir gerne das Thema zu, also quasi wir wollen mal anfangen damit, dass wir eine Frage stellen. Also wir stellen in der Sendung eine Frage, dann sind die Leitungen geschaltet. Rufen sie jetzt an.
Ja.
Äh und.
Nur die Nummer neben ihrer Landesflagge.
Nur die Nummer, die wir Landesflagge, neunzehn Cent pro Anruf aus dem Niveau.
Ganz normal.
Äh Festnetz ist inzwischen eine Festnetzfett, ist einfach inzwischen so äh,
So Standard, dass man das als wahrscheinlich ausreichend kostengünstiges Angebot sehen kann. Ähm wir haben einfach eine Berliner Nummer,
Wir stellen eine Frage und äh die wird dann einfach, wenn wenn ihr da anruft, wiederholt sich einfach diese Frage und dann habt ihr dreißig Sekunden Zeit äh da was zu sagen. Alles, was ihr dort sagt, kann und wird in der Sendung gegen euch verwendet werden,
Und äh wir wollen einfach mal gucken, ob das ein wir wollen das Experiment mal machen. Und gucken, was dabei.
Wie das aufgenommen wird, ob das, ob das eine, ob das ein Weg ist mit einem besseren, besseren Feedback-Kanal, eine bessere Nähe.
Mal jetzt.
Gar nicht so viel rein. Ich hab ja schon ausführlich diskutiert, ich hab ja schon so ein bisschen meine Erfahrung gesammelt und man darf sich halt nicht zu viele Illusionen machen über Medienbrüche und Audio und ähm
was was das dann auch psychologisch mit einem macht in dem Moment, also Text hat so seine Freiheiten, die Audio oder nicht hat und umgekehrt und äh deswegen gehen wir da einfach jetzt einen ganz einfachen Weg,
Eine einzige Frage, nur auf die sollt ihr antworten und es gilt wie früher bei Münzfernsprecher, fasse dich kurz. Ja
Wir wollen keine epischen, ausführlichen Darlegungen, weil der Anrufbeantworter macht dann sowieso relativ äh schnell auch den Hahn wieder zu. So, äh ich denke, dass man irgendwie in zwanzig Sekunden vielleicht dreißig äh eigentlich alles rübergebracht haben müsste äh in der Kürze liegt die Würze
und ähm wir werden.
Die Frage ist auch die Frage, die wir uns jetzt ausgedacht haben, ist ja auch sehr einfach. Die ist simpel, ja.
Sehr einfach. Genau und wir wollen nämlich von euch einfach wissen, was ein Lok Buch Nest Politik scheiße ist.
Da könnt ihr mal drüber nachdenken.
Oder auch nicht.
Maul aufmachen.
Und jetzt kommen wir zur Durchsage der Telefonnummer,
Das ist die null drei null für Berlin, einhundertzwanzig, achtundachtzig, drei achtundachtzig. Null drei null hundertzwanzig achtundachtzig drei achtundachtzig. Die Leitungen sind jetzt geschaltet.
Wäre die Sendung nur live.
Subscribe, willst du noch von der Subscribe erzählen?
Kann ich machen, weil die war ja der Grund, warum unsere letzte Sendung nicht äh oder diese Sendung nicht pünktlich ist und so weiter.
Du mir wieder nix zum du mir wieder nix zum Logbuch Netz für Tick Geburtstag geschenkt hast. Ich habe das zu Hause gesessen.
Ja, genau. Und geweint.
Und hab irgendwann abends dem Tim um viertel vor zwölf du hast nicht angerufen getextet.
Immer das gleiche.
Vergisst du meinen, immer, vergisst du unseren Hochzeitstag.
Eben noch der har Typen dann irgendwie ein emotionales Wrack.
Und Tim äh war in in München.
Bei nicht beim hessischen Rundfunk, sondern beim bayrischen Rundfunk und hat dort die Surpscripe besucht und mit äh mit mit ausge.
Ausgerichtet.
Ja genau, so kann man das glaube ich ganz gut beschreiben. Also das ist ja auch ein Community-Afford. Äh vor allem äh geht da der Dank an äh Claudia und Ralf, die halt äh im Wesentlichen das Programm zusammengehämmert haben,
und natürlich den zahlreichen Helfern vor Ort, weil das halt auch so ein bisschen so mitmachen,
Ist jetzt auch nicht übermäßig viel zu tun, so, ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir da jetzt enge Schichten planen oder so, aber die Kamera muss geführt werden, da braucht man sozusagen beim Recording äh ein bisschen Hilfe, das ist eigentlich auch im Wesentlichen schon die Geschichte.
Podcast äh Konferenz beim Recording Hilfe zu brauchen, hast du doch relativ schnell ein Bike-Chat stehen, oder?
Tatsächlich ist das alles sehr äh unkompliziert. Also.
Wie viele Leute waren da? Also nur so um die einhundertfünfzig Leute.
Hundertfünfzig Leute waren's diesmal. Ja, ist ein bisschen gewachsen.
Vater. Das war die neunte, ne? Ich weiß net, die zweite oder dritte in Berlin, da waren aber vielleicht, da waren vielleicht vierzig, fünfzig.
Ja ja,
Genau, das ist so langsam irgendwie immer so zehn Leute mehr gefühlt und ähm das ist mir eigentlich auch sehr recht, weil ich ich mag das, wenn wenn man so ein kontrolliertes, überschaubares Wachstum hat
Nichtsdestotrotz hatte ich ehrlich gesagt insgeheim auch schon auf hundertfünfzig gehofft dieses Mal,
haben sich dann so auf den letzten Metern viele erst
entschieden, gut ist auch nicht so überraschend. Manche wissen vielleicht nicht, ob sie Zeit haben äh ne, dann redet man mehr darüber, dass man dahin fährt und dann kriegen's andere vielleicht auch erst kurzfristig mit, et cetera, wie das eben so ist
Das fand ich dann aber auch genau die richtige Zahl. Also es war sehr angenehm.
Und das sind alles Menschen, die auch Podcasts machen oder auch hier natürlich auch Entwickler oder sag mal was.
Also es gab glaube ich so vier, vielleicht fünf äh Gruppen, die man unterscheiden muss. Am stärksten ist auf jeden Fall Podcast da, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal
so die die Kernzielgruppe, ja? Das Ganze ist ja, sagen wir mal, geboren aus der Podcastszene und das ist vor allem das Thema.
Und die sind dann da, um Erik irgendwie beim Mittagessen überm Schnaps noch schnell so ein Feature Request reinzudrücken oder hm nein, das leider das machst nur du.
Ich mache das nicht beim Schnaps.
Nee, du rufst ihn einfach nachts an und sagst, ich wär's jetzt so, nein, Scherz.
Schreibt den die ganze Zeit im Chat voll. Ähm,
Nee, ich glaube, dass die sich tatsächlich über all das austauschen wollen, was auch auf der Subscribe ein Thema ist, weil ich meine das ganze Vortragsprogramm waren,
Einreichung, wir haben uns fast geahnt, wenn man relativ wenig,
angeregtes äh Inhaltsmaterial gehabt, alles wurde irgendwie aus freien Stücken im Vorfeld äh eingereicht mit sehr wenigen Ausnahmen und auch das Workshop-Programm, was sich da abzeichnet, ist ja komplett,
Communitybase. So und ja, was, was für Workshops wollt ihr machen? Ah ja, zack, tragt das ins Forum ein. Bäm, bam, bam, dann wird das irgendwie auf dem Zeitplan verteilt, fertig ist die Laube.
Da wurde über alles geredet, da wurde über Formate geredet, da wurde über irgendwie mache ich Interviews, wie plane ich eine Sendung, was gibt's für rechtliche Fragen, was gibt's für finanzielle Fragen, was gibt's für äh organisatorische Fragen, was habe ich so für Erfahrungen in der Hörerkommunikation gesammelt,
alles möglich. Also die Podcaster sind natürlich die stärkste Gruppe. Ein paar Hörer sind da,
Es sind dann halt auch viele Entwickler da, Leute, die es vielleicht selber gerne Podcast hören, aber nicht unbedingt selber welche machen, die aber andere Stärken haben, die irgendwie in dieses Ökosystem auch gerne was äh zurückgeben wollen auf ihrer Art.
So würde ich ja fast diese ganze Pott Love Community äh fast subsumieren, oder? Menschen, die äh sorry.
Studiolink. Also all die ganzen Projekte, die daraus entstanden sind, ist sind definitiv alles so Podcast äh Affine,
Leute, deren Stärken aber eben jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr quatschen äh sind, dass sie jetzt der Meinung sind, sie müssen jetzt selber einen Kanal aufmachen, sondern die das irgendwie einfach,
nett finden, weil ist ja auch wirklich eine eine wunderbar angenehme, nette Szene, also das davon waren alle wieder total geprellt, wie nice irgendwie alle,
die exzellente alle so äh zueinander waren und ja und das trägt ja dann eben auch äh dieses
äh Entwicklermodell, ne? Weil du kommst halt als Developer dahin und die wird halt einfach auch gleich äh universelle Dankbarkeit aus allen Richtungen zuteilen, weil du siehst halt so, ah, das sind die Leute, die benutzen das auch und die erzeugen damit genau das, was ich eigentlich auch selber,
haben will und wenn man sich schaut
äh wenn man sich hier anschaut, was da in den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren äh passiert ist, hast du es ja eingangs schon erwähnt, dass es äh teilweise wirklich beeindrucken,
Und ähm mittlerweile kann sich das ja eben auch mit mit äh sehr, sehr, sehr teuren Systemen da draußen nicht nur messen, sondern gibt eben auch im Prinzip schon so ein bisschen äh vor, wo der Hase eigentlich so lang laufen sollte.
Es hört einfach auf.
Jetzt hört's nicht mehr auf. Und äh.
Genau. Dann gibt's ein zunehmendes Interesse aus dem öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunk.
Leute aus der Schweiz, da Leute aus Österreich da, WDR, ähm, so natürlich auch bayrischer Rundfunk,
Die waren jetzt nicht eine besonders große Gruppe, aber man merkt schon, dass,
dass da gerade was beginnt und das,
spitze hält auch auf mehreren Ebenen ab, ne. Einerseits sind's halt so Leute, die eben versuchen, in ihren schwerfälligen
Dinge in irgendeine Richtung zu treiben, die irgendwie in Online
neuen Formaten oder anderen Hörerinteraktionen in irgendeiner Form investiert sind, da versuchen eigene Projekte zu starten oder das auch schon zu äh tun,
Einerseits.
Also sind das dann jetzt frage jetzt, muss ja nicht Leute, die sowas machen wie äh Zündfunk oder Breitband oder wie diese,
Netznahen Sendungen heißen oder sind das inzwischen sogar äh Leute, die,
eine andere Rolle im Sender haben. Also jetzt nicht unbedingt die ich bin ich bin die Person, die Tech und Jugend und Games macht und oder so.
Also von den letzten Nahen Sendungen hätte ich mir ehrlich gesagt noch ein bisschen mehr Beteiligung gewünscht. Ich weiß ja auch, dass es Interesse gab, aber teilweise einfach terminlich nicht
klappt hat, weil wir hatten das halt in die Herbstferien gelegt in Berliner Herbstferien, das ist dann nicht für jeden mit Kindern und so weiter, das war so ein bisschen suboptimal, müssen wir auch nochmal schauen, wie wir das besser legen können,
Es war mehr so Leute, die halt ähm was weiß ich, der BR hat ja auch dann eigene Projekte mittlerweile angestoßen und äh so Call for Podcasts und solche äh Sachen, das haben sie dann da halt also Leute, die auch ganz konkret schon
Podcasting innerhalb des ÖR voranbringen, ne? Und auch Projekte beteiligen. Sowas war dabei.
Also die betrachten das jetzt nicht mehr nur als ach ja wir können einen Audioaufzeichnung der Sendung auf unserer Webseite veröffentlichen und dann.
Sondern sie verstehen langsam, also es gibt halt auch schon so, wir machen jetzt etwa wir machen hier einen Podcast, der läuft nicht im normalen Programm. Das war ja vor ein paar Jahren auch noch
vorstellbar, ne? Oder eben wir sehen das irgendwie in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein wenig als Talentschuppen, ne? Wobei
Da ist auch noch ein großer Weg zu gehen, da ist viel Radioprägung, die man glaube ich so leicht nicht wegbekommt. Und dann gibt's so einen Teil von Leuten.
Die ähm das ist eigentlich so das, was ich am interessantesten finde persönlich.
Sehr viele der Leute, die im Radio als Journalist unterwegs sind, sind ja selbstständig.
Wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Und sehen natürlich auch, dass so diese Perspektive langfristige Anstellungen im öffentlichen Rundfunk ist nicht mehr so wie früher
ne? Und kann halt auch gut sein, dass das so nicht stattfindet. Also dieses freie äh Netzwerken und sich auch selber in gewisser Hinsicht als eigene Marke pitchen müssen, ja
führt jetzt immer wichtiger und wie machst du das am besten.
Ja klar machst du einen Podcast.
Hast du äh einen Podcast oder anders ausgesucht, selbst wenn du das noch nicht machst, siehst du zumindest, dass die Leute die Podcast machen? Eigentlich genau das wunderbar gut können,
diesen Ausspielungsweg für sich so gewählt haben und darüber halt Dinge lernen, sich selbst vermarkten lernen
und das war ja auch so ein so ein Thema auf dieser Subscribe auch sich hinzunehmenden Maße Gedanken machen, wie man vielleicht sogar darauf eine professionelle Karriere aufsetzen kann und äh auch sein Maniflo äh darauf aufsetzen kann
ohne eben jetzt die ganze Zeit nur in dieser Hoffnungshaltung zu sein. Na ja, wenn ich mich genug anstrenge, dann werde ich schon irgendwann so gut unterkommen, dass es dann irgendwie auch läuft.
Du kannst vor allem ja, du kannst vor allem dann mal deine
Konzeptkreativität auch einfach mal ausleben in so einem Podcast, ne? Also ich bin großer Fan des Deutschlandfunks, ganz gar keine Frage, aber es ist auch sehr klar, dass sie ganz äh strenge Schablonen haben wie eine Sendung
ist. Und da kannst du dich als Sprecherin oder als äh,
äh Autor des äh des Features oder so nur auf eine gewisse Weise hervortun. Du kannst deiner Recherchearbeit gut machen und ne, aber du kannst da jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, heute,
Lars von Trier Dogma, ich werfe alles um wir meißeln jetzt die Sendung in Stein oder so, ne? Also das das geht eben nicht. Du bist ein anderes Korsett der Zeit gebunden, du bist äh,
ne, und da kann man wahrscheinlich gar nicht mir vorstellen, dass das für äh den ein oder andere Person dann auch mal eben spannend ist, einfach
und sei es nur zu wissen, diese Sendung muss nicht aufbiegen und brechen auf vierundfünfzig Minuten geschnitten werden.
Also da bewegt sich was und dann gibt's noch
andere Leute, die sich jetzt nicht so gut fassen lassen, äh teilweise halt Leute, die versuchen, da in dem Bereich jetzt irgendwie äh Werbung, Marketing, andere Konzepte zu machen, das waren aber sehr wenige,
ja? Ähm.
Ach so, hier hör mal, was ist mit den ähm was ist hier mit diesen ganzen Verlagen? Also das ist jetzt auch eine eine Welle äh das jetzt im Prinzip.
Plötzlich, als hätten die sich alle abgesprochen. Ähm äh von den Verlagen in den letzten Monaten,
Podcast kommt, ne? Zeit online, Spiegel online
Süddeutsche Zeitung, ich komme da gar nicht mehr hinterher. Ähm Rheinische Post und was nicht alles, ne? Und äh auch teilweise mit äh wo das echt denkst du ach ist echt ein gewitztes Konzept
wie die das durchziehen ähm.
Das war ein bisschen schade, weil da äh hatten wir eigentlich schon den Kontakt, aber die
konnten alle eben aus diesen genannten Terminen äh Problem nicht, sowohl die Maria, die ja die Sachen für äh Zeit online macht als auch jetzt äh bei Spiegel online. Die werden kommen, aber ging dann nicht,
wir hatten dafür den Luca von dem T3N Magazin. Das Computermagazin da, die ja das auch schon sehr viel länger machen. Ja,
da schon sehr viel früher ihre Nase äh äh drin äh so und ihre Hände drin gebadet haben quasi und das jetzt auch regelmäßig machen und ich das eben auch genauso eine gute Ergänzung finde zum Beispiel in
in dem Fall. Ähm
Ja, das war auch so ein Thema und das ist auch etwas, was glaube ich noch äh so weitergehen wird, weil ich glaube auch, dass viele von diesen Experimenten werden irgendwie noch ein halbes Jahr auf jeden Fall äh da sein.
Mhm. Ach so, du mal, also ein halbes Jahr da sein, weil dann ist die nächste Subscrib.
Dann sollte zumindest äh die Länder.
Wäre ein sehr verkapptes Getränk. Das wird schon noch ein halbes Jahr machen.
Nee, ne.
Bis das ähm ja.
Ja, wir wollen ja unseren Halbjahreszyklus eigentlich wieder aufgreifen. Äh ist noch nicht ganz klar, wohin wir als nächstes gehen, ob wir eine Location in Berlin finden, die äh passt,
es gibt äh eine andere Stadt, wo es aussieht, dass klappen könnte. Und ich hätte auch gar nichts dagegen, ähm
Die Veranstaltung ein bisschen zu so einer Wandervogelveranstaltung zu machen, wo wir vielleicht an drei äh Standorten äh herumzirkulieren, dass sozusagen alles mal im Frühjahr und alles mal im Herbst dran sein kann
und ich bin auch ein großer Freund von so einem Halbjahreszyklus. Das ist äh das das bringt nochmal eine ganz andere Energie, gerade in dieses Community-Building. Also einmal im Jahr, weißt du und dann kannste man nicht und dann ist schon zwei Jahre und so.
Das ist schon gar nicht so schlecht.
Jetzt habe ich äh die Freakshow gehört und da gewann man fast den Eindruck, dass er bei der ganzen Subscribe nur da rumgegangen, wie man denn jetzt irgendwie aus seinem Podcast Geld machen kann.
Ja, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen so ein herrschendes Mem. Das stimmt natürlich, dass das eine Rolle gespielt hat. War also sagen wir mal so, von den Themen, die hervorstachen, war es das, was am häufigsten ähm.
In also in in den meisten oder Talks. Na nicht in den meisten Talks oder was am häufigsten intox erwähnt wurde. So.
Tja, auch das gehört äh dazu, wenn äh etwas groß wird, ne. Ich habe das äh,
ich habe da mit einem äh guten Freund auch so regelmäßig äh.
Irgendwie Gespräche, der dann irgendwie sagt, ja, bist du eigentlich verrückt? Überleg mal, was ihr für einen für Menschen erreicht, was du darf. Wenn du da Werbeanzeigen äh,
machst dann brauchst du nicht mehr arbeiten zu gehen und
Wir haben ja auch irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren äh fing das ja dann auch anders regelmäßig Angebote oder Anfragen kamen. Und dann diskutieren wir zum Beispiel darüber, diese ganzen US-Podcasts, ne, dass ähm,
die die Werbung ja mit der eigenen Stimme vorlesen.
Native heißt es.
Native, Edvertising oder was, ja. Ähm wo äh mein guter Freund äh,
Roland, er sei gegrüßt an dieser Stelle, sagt, dass er das total gut findet, weil das ihn am wenigsten stört beim Konsumieren des Podcasts. Stimmt natürlich auch, ne? Wer jetzt irgendwie anders wenn äh du sitzt da irgendwie und dann kommt auf einmal
wie früher, wenn man wenn man Fernsehen geguckt hat, dann irgendwie so der Sat eins Ball, dann kommen die B zwanzig. Werbe oder es gibt ja auch Radiosender, bei denen es das gi
die hören manche Leute ja auch, manchmal stehen die.
Ja, sowas kann einen total rausreißen.
So. Genau, das äh aber das hört sich ein bisschen mit dieser eigenen, mit dieser eigenen Stimme vorlesen. Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt,
sowas von grenzwertig.
Weil du da nämlich mitverkaufst das Vertrauensverhältnis, was die äh Hörerschaft zu dir hat. Das finde ich also,
wirklich weiß ich nicht, ist das, ist so was wäre das erlaubt in Deutschland? Ich hab grade bei T
Stadler hier einen Artikel gelesen über Influencer Marketing da steht er dran, also muss gekennzeichnet sein, ist ja sogar bei diesen Amis, die sagen dann letztendlich Sponsor hier
Hast du nicht gesehen, dies oder jene Matratz.
Talk about our Friends.
At Casper und dann kommen die in den auf diese amerikanische Weise, ey ich, ich schlafe sowas von. Du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen, wie gut ich gestern wieder geschlafen habe. Hi, Love it. Und du denkst, also das äh finde ich,
es gibt aber auch welche, die machen das unglaublich, die machen das wirklich witzig, der macht Spaß, also da kann man sich auch echt drauf freuen,
dass sie wieder irgendwie so 'ne Sendung dass sie jetzt wieder irgendwie 'ne Werbung verhunzen den Potsafe America Leute zum Beispiel, ne?
Na ja, die verhunzen sie nämlich nicht, die machen die natürlich noch viel, viel geiler,
Also die die machen diese Werbung noch viel besser, ne? Also dieses diese Mehmsel, die habe ich jetzt in meinem normalen Leben schon, dass ich irgendwie sage Cash App oder irgend so ein Scheiß, ja? Das, also das
wirkt und das finde ich beängstigend und das finde ich finde ich äh ehrlich gesagt ethisch total verwerflich, sowas zu machen. Kommt für mich überhaupt nicht in Frage. Finde ich total daneben
Ganz ehrlich, auch wenn ich dir selber Freude dran habe, äh finde ich, dass äh absolut ähm perfide.
Ja, mir geht's ja ähnlich
nun auch schon zwölf Jahre Podcasting auf dem Buckel und hab bisher noch jedem Werbeangebot wieder stehen können
nicht, dass keins kam, ne? Also ganz im Gegenteil, da äh wurde glaube ich von allem, was hier überall woanders schon mal gehört hat, das hat ja auch alles schon mal angeklopft. So und ähm,
Na ja, ich finde es auch.
Problematisch, also muss ja immer zwei Sachen trennen, ne? Was andere für richtig halten,
was andere machen, das ist eine, so. Welche Entscheidung man für sich selber fällt. Was ist das, was man gleich äh vorweggeschoben so,
Mich stört halt genau das, was du sagst. Diese Vermischung, weil ich halt irgendwie das Gefühl habe, ich verlasse mich selbst.
Ich wenn ich rede, wird die will ich immer,
Möchte ich immer, dass ich aus mir selbst herausspreche und nicht etwas anderes. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen also als wenn so ein Geist,
in dich reinzieht in so einem schlechten Fantasy Movie, ja, wo dann so Horntit bist und auf einmal irgendwie,
wie heißen diese Leute, die so diese die Verstorbenen heraufbeschwören, genau diesen genau Medium.
Sehr interessanter Vergleich, ja. Genau.
Will ja ein Medium sein und nicht ein Medium.
Ja.
Ja, also äh ihr sprechen nicht eure Verstorbenen Uhr an, irgendwie äh zu euch,
Jetzt gibt's viele Leute, die sagen
ist mir egal, ich kriege das doch irgendwie gefiltert, ich weiß doch, wie es gemeint ist und la und es ja auch gut so und dann kriegt ihr da euer Geld und dann wird das finanziert und dann ertrage ich das auch,
Und das verstehe ich auch.
Ist völlig in Ordnung und ähm man muss auch sagen, die ähm,
Es ist auch wirklich erstaunlich. Wie lange sich diese deutsche Podcastszene ähm.
Gegen die verschiedenen Versuche der Kommerzialisierung, die herangetragen wurden. Ganz ohne Zweifel gewährt hat,
Ne? Also ich erinnere mich noch vor ein paar Jahren war das. Da äh kamen hier Audible an,
die haben doch dann irgendwie wollten erstens glaube ich Werbung für ihr Hörbuchding da machen, wie sie's bei den Amis ja auch schon hatten in dem Pot,
Klar ist doch auch logisch, die die verkaufen Hörbücher. Also oder oder Hörbuchabos ist doch klar, dass sie äh dass du zu Podcastern gehst, ja? Ähm also finde ich, finde ich total verständlich. Hm, sind die aber auch so weit gegangen, dass hier
in ihrer Plattform Audible Podcast veröffentlicht haben woll,
wo ich denke so, Alter, was ist das denn? Ey, wir äh wir bauen hier irgendwie seit weiß nicht, wie viel Jahren diese eigenen Infrastrukturen, Podcasts, ist das einzige Medium, was noch
so dezentral erscheint, ja? Äh,
in den in den Dankpott Love Dank die anderer äh Podcasting äh Infrastrukturen auch diese äh Ami-Podcast Szene immer schön selbst gehostete, eigene Seiten und so.
Und jetzt sollen wir das irgendwie bei so einem, bei so einem US-Unternehmen reintragen.
Gibt's auch welche aus Berlin, wo du das machen kannst und das tun ja auch einige.
Dass da wiederum äh ich weiß nicht welche du jetzt gerade welches.
Soundcloudmatisch.
Ja okay, aber sorry, SoundCloud hat ein ganz anderes Angebot. Soundcloud bietet dir an, wir hauen deinen Podcast. Macht ja sogar Spiegel online, die haust du in ihrem Podcast ja da. Ähm
die sagen aber nicht äh pass mal auf, wir haben voll geile Idee,
wir nehmen den Leuten zehn Euro im Monat ab, äh für ein Abo-Modell, damit die unsere, damit die unser Ding da nutzen und wir bezahlen dich dafür, dass du da auch noch irgendwas reinträgst und deine mühsam angetragenen, deine mühsam
gesammelten Podcast-Enthusiasten jetzt mal schön bei uns reinzerst, damit wir die mit dem mit dem zehn Euro Abo im Monat verarzten können.
Okay, also es ist kein World Garden, das stimmt.
Ne, also dass da verrückt. Aber äh so auch da kann man natürlich sagen, gibt Geld und wer das äh wem das wichtig ist, der hat da äh konnte das machen,
ja? Und ähm es ist halt, es wird zunehmend schwierig für äh,
Menschen mit äh mit strengeren Prinzipien ähm die auch sich selber gegenüber,
aufrechtzuerhalten und zu rechtfertig.
Ja, wenn äh alle um dich herum äh umkippen, denkst du ja auch noch so. Okay. Was mache ich.
Umkippen ist, ne? So.
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen.
Ist, es ist ein hartes äh hart ins Gesicht gehen, aber.
Die anderen gehen alle zum Strand so und stehst da noch im.
Und du stehst halt da und sagst halt, ey Leute, Balkonien so, wir haben den Balkon bezahlt.
So. Wird wird wird schwierig.
Die Straße ist doch gar nicht so laut.
Und ähm da geht er noch mit einher, was sich also mit diesen.
Mir ist dieser Gedanke.
Ähm ich will Logbuch, Netzpolitik, monetarisieren, ich will davon leben können oder so oder ich will damit möglichst viel Geld machen. Der ist mir,
richtig fremd. Und der ist ja auf eine Weise fremd, dass mir, dass sich das,
dass ich mich ich persönlich mich jetzt, ne? Also wie gesagt, kein Urteil über andere. Ich würde mich dabei schlecht fühlen, das zu machen. Ähm,
Ich hätte, ich würde mich dabei schlecht fühlen, hier regelmäßig ähm irgendwie zum zum Spenden für die Sendung aufzurufen. Ähm,
Ich würde mich damit schlecht fühlen, hier dreimal pro Sendung auf meinen Amazon Link aufmerksam zu machen.
Oder jeden Spender einzeln noch vorzulesen.
Das tue ich. Äh ich ganz am Ende die also wer.
Ganz am Ende der Sendung kommt diese ganz kurze Episode, wo ich ein paar Namen danke sage. Das sind diejenigen, die sich in der Woche oder seit der letzten Sendung, die bei mir
namentlich aufgefallen sind. Gibt verschiedene Wege. Wer äh irgendwie sucht, findet, wie man sich bei mir
erkenntlich sein kann für das was ich hier mache. Ähm ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn das passiert,
Ganz ehrlich. Klar natürlich, ne? Also das sind dann äh wenn sowas hier von der Amazon Wunschliste kommt und dann irgendwie noch ein netter äh netter äh Text dabei ist, so gibt echt nichts schöneres, als äh sowas im Briefkasten zu finden,
finde ich total toll. Gleichzeitig.
Würde ich mich jetzt äh und und ich habe auch diesen über diesen Affiliate-Link kommt auch äh immer mal wieder so ein kleiner Amazon-Gutschein, findet dann seinen Weg zu mir und dann kann ich mir äh selber was kaufen,
oder was was ist etwas billiger was ich schon immer haben wollte. Aber und das ist wirklich toll, aber ich kämme mir irgendwie für mich ist das keine.
Option, das hier in jeder Sendung fünfmal zu sagen ist ein,
und es gibt keinen Grund dafür, lange Diskussionen mit Roland, mit dem ich da in letzter Zeit so viel darüber gesprochen habe. Äh der sagt so, er macht doch, wenn dir das vor, wenn dich das freut, dann kannst du es doch auch sagen,
Konto durchgeben oder so und die Bereitschaft ist ja vor allem auch offenbar da bei äh bei den bei den äh bei den Hörerschaft so. Warum sollte man das äh ablehnen.
Ich kann's mir selber ich denk da halt äh ich mach das hier irgendwie aus einer anderen Motivation heraus. So ich freue mich über jedes Dankeschön aber ich ähm.
Bin irgendwie für mich fühlt es sich persönlich gut an, dass ich mein Geld auf eine andere Weise verdiene und ähm mir damit die Freiheit,
er kaufe ähm das hier zu tun.
Oder auch sein zu lassen.
Oder auch mal sein zu lassen, ja. Aber wenn dann, wenn man dann so sieht, was andere Leute auch aufrufen, gibt ja jetzt dann auch Podcaster, die irgendwie wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, sowas äh,
sagen wie diese Sendung machen wir nur weiter, wenn wir monatlich so und so viel Betrag Y dafür kriegen und dann habe ich, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal darüber nachgedacht, wie gesagt, weil mir dieser Gedanke eben nicht so nahe liegt,
habe ich mal äh gedacht, boah, will jetzt gar nicht sagen, wer um wen es da ging. Ähm und da habe ich gedacht, aha, okay, das sind zwei Personen, die diese Sendung machen. Dann habe ich mal diesen Betrag, den sie da gesehen, genommen haben und dann habe ich mal gedacht, würde ich.
Für diesen Betrag ein Logbuch machen und der Betrag war dreistellig. Na, jetzt sind dreistelliger Betrag, den die quasi pro Sendung haben wollten,
und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ähm.
Klingt jetzt sehr assi, wenn ich das sage. Das wäre zu wenig. Weil der Aufwand ist höher als äh dass man jetzt sagen könnte ähm.
Für ein paar hundert Euro würde ich eine Sendung Logbuch machen und dann äh also die Zeit, die ich dafür brauche,
mehr und in der Zeit, die ich brauche, könnte ich auf anderem Wege ähm besser verdienen,
Ne, also ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag,
musste mit so und so viel veranschlagen und dann kannst du dir ausrechnen, wat für von, weiß ich nicht, so und so viel hundert Euro überbleiben würde und dann kannst du halt überlegen, ist das ein Tag? Und dann worauf ich hinaus will, ist die Forderung, die die dieses Podcast paar,
aufgestellt hat, war nicht zu hoch.
Moderat. Das war, wäre immer noch ähm eine schlechte Bezahlung gewesen, für die sie eine Sendung gemacht hätten,
Und das war, das war für mich so ein interessiert äh interessanter Blick,
dass ich mir, dass ich gedacht habe, nee, krass ist eigentlich eine diese Honorarvorstellung, die da jetzt vorgetragen wird, ist,
nicht verkehrt. Die ist nicht die ist nicht reist. Ähm obwohl sie auf anhiebt, reist, mit Reist erschienen, war sie nicht. Und ähm dann wiederum denke ich mir.
Ich würd's genau deshalb würde ich's nicht machen wollen, weil dann mach ich's lieber kostenlos und ohne von irgendjemandem dafür Geld zu verlangen ähm und äh
und genieße und behalte die Freude daran und lasse auch einfach mal eine Sendung ausfallen, wenn mir gerade nicht danach ist oder wenn es der,
Wenn es der Kalender gerade mal nicht zulässt, weil ich eben äh gezwungen bin auf andere Weise mein Geld zu verdienen,
Das ist so meine meine äh mein mein Gefühl zu diesem Thema.
Tim guckt nur.
Ja, ich warte jetzt noch auf eine Schlussfolgerung. Ist das die Schlussfolgerung?
Schlussfolgerung ist, ich will, ich habe eigentlich keine Lust, diesen Podcast zu äh gezielt äh zu monetarisieren. Ich freue mich immer über ein Dankeschön.
Ähm aber der Wandel also was ich feststelle ist, dass diese Hemmung.
Die diese Community hatte für.
Belohnung für Unterstützung oder sonst was zu werben in zunehmendem Maße schwinden,
bis zu dem bis zu einem Punkt, der äh den ich dann als als Hörer schon äh teilweise als als störende empfinde.
Na gut, ich meine äh was damit jetzt einhergeht.
Und und so und das ist jetzt ja nur so meine, das ist jetzt die Stimme eines Hörers, ja ähm und die Frage ist, was mache ich mit meinem Podcast,
Oder was mach was machen wir mit unserem Podcast? Wie reagieren wir darauf? Fangen wir jetzt auch an und sagen irgendwie machen machen irgendwelche.
Spielchen oder sagen wir ja man kann uns unterstützen und wenn ihr uns hier bewertet und da und dann kriegen wir und hier kriegen wir fünf Prozent, wenn ihr euch einen Windelabo bestellt und.
Ja kann man alles machen so.
Kann man machen und ich frage mich halt so und äh ich habe da ganz ehrlich, ich habe da auch zwei ähm.
Zwei hilft das Engelchen und Teufelchen. Ich habe dann irgendwie so Engelchen gesagt, irgendwie äh Liebeseck kommen.
Und ich habe Teufelchen Roland, der sagt, nehm das Geld.
Und wer ist das Englisch.
Das Ängelchen ist irgendwie wie Engelchen so sind, ne? Stehen am Ende, sind am Ende die gearsch.
Mein Herz ist rein, mein Portemonnaie ist klein.
Um jetzt nicht für zu viel Verwirrung äh zu sorgen und sich vielleicht auch nochmal vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen aufdröseln, wie hier eigentlich so das Modell ist, ne? Weil ich habe ja jetzt nochmal eine andere Herangehensweise. Ich habe Linos äh angesprochen am Anfang,
Story hat man ja schon und die Mieterebene wirft jetzt.
Kein Geld ab, mit der ich irgendwie Angestellte,
äh finanzieren könnte oder auch nur nennenswerte Beteiligung an Mitstreiter machen kann. Der Deal war eigentlich immer ein so ähm.
Nein.
Man äh ich schaffe sozusagen die Produktionsbasis und äh eben mit dem,
verhältnismäßigen mit der mit der mit der existierenden äh Reichweite, die ich halt äh über die Jahre
gesammelt habe, verschaffe ich halt auch neuen Projekten, damit neue Reichweite und ich denke, dass auch
sich bisher hier noch keiner so richtig äh beklagen konnte, wenn ich mir so die Reaktion auf zahlreiche Formate anschaue, was auch immer äh sozusagen hier äh in den ähm,
in den Ablaufmotor geraten ist, hat für alle Beteiligten auch was gebracht.
Man hat auch, also wenn ich jetzt mal ganz kurz hier wir stehen hier in einem
eigenen Studio mit irgendwie Equipment, ich will gar nicht wissen, was das alles gekostet hat und einer perfekten Produktionstoolchain äh das ist
ne? Also wenn der Tim jetzt hier mit Koidkätchen säße, dann würde ich mir da irgendwann mal drüber Gedanken machen, aber äh solange der Tipp seine äh sein
solange der Tim mir jetzt hier nicht auffällt durch durch durch irgendwelche Reichtümer bin ich sehr froh was was hier eben auch an
an Programm entsteht, dass ich ja auch alles konsumiere. Ich freue mich ja auf die Schili.
Warum, warum ich das jetzt erwähne ist, ein paar Leute mögen sich jetzt vielleicht gewundert haben, weil es gibt natürlich jetzt Spenden für die Meterebene, ja? Es gibt sozusagen einen einen Kanal, der aber nicht groß äh differenziert, weil ich äh halt auch,
für mich ist ja so auch am Anfang die Entscheidung gewesen,
Wie viel von dem, was ich mache, wird jetzt im Rahmen von solchen Auftragsarbeiten äh laufen, ne? Das ist ja, sagen wir mal, das Nächste, wo ich quasi an so einer,
Monetarisierung oder Kommerzialisierung dran bin. Ich mach für andere Organisationen die ich mir allerdings sehr gut aussuche ja? Äh wo auch eigentlich überhaupt kein.
Stiftung, Wissenschafts.
Ja, es sind keine Marken und das ist kein kein Bullshit so, ne.
Inhaltlich interessierte.
Genau, Sachen, die,
die ich auch extrem interessant finde, die ich auch sonst gerne machen würde und die dadurch halt sozusagen ermöglicht werden so und und wo auch eine
wo auch eine eine intensive Kooperation ist, ne? Also insbesondere was jetzt in den letzten Jahren mit mit Forschergeist, in dem
dem Stifter
abgelaufen ist, wie viel mir da auch zugearbeitet wird, auf welche Ideen die auch selber kommen, jetzt hier mit diesen lustigen neuen äh Podcast äh Werbevideos und so weiter, also das das ist das ist ganz toll so und das sind einfach auch belebende äh Sachen
das den Fokus Europa jetzt mit der Böllstiftung hat jetzt
heute gerade sozusagen die neue, wir sind jetzt sozusagen in Season Two und jetzt hat auch da äh die Zuarbeit eine neue äh Qualität bekommen, das wird man sicherlich dann äh merken in den nächsten Monaten. Also das sind alles,
Raumzeit kriegt endlich Unterstützung hier vom vom Planetarium, wo ich ja auch jetzt in zwei Wochen irgendwie live vor Ort sein werde, da Sendungen machen werde.
Das wusste ich noch gar nicht. Genau. Ich will ein Ticket.
Dann musst du aber schnell.
Muss ich kaufen. Ja, okay.
Oh ganz schnell. Ähm also,
Ne, das sind alles diese Sachen und das andere ist quasi so mein freies Programm. So, wo ich halt irgendwie darüber entschieden habe, über die Jahre hinweg, okay, was, was mache ich mit wem in welcher Regelmäßigkeit und und äh dieser Spendenkanal
ist quasi äh für diese Produktion. So. Jetzt schreiben natürlich die Leute rein. Ja
finde das toll, finde das toll, finde das toll, dann steht da ja und Lockbuchnetzbotheke und Freakshow und ich höre äh auch immer gerne Raumzeit und ich höre auch dieses und jenes und was weiß ich, da kommt auch mal eine Spende rein für eine Auftragsproduktion, weißt du? Also wo das vielleicht gar nicht so differenziert äh wahrgenommen äh äh wird
dass das an sich erstmal,
ein ohnehin schon finanzierter äh Kanal ist oder wo es den Leuten vielleicht auch egal ist, ja, weil weil ja darüber auch nochmal eine ganz andere äh Form der Anerkennung auch äh reingespielt wird so. Und das, das ist halt, sagen wir mal so der äh der Grundstamm.
Aber es ist für mich unmöglich äh in der aktuellen Struktur ähm
Da jetzt aus diesen kleinst Spendenanmerkungen bei Überweisungen irgendwie halbwegs äh etwas herauszuziehen, was jetzt zum Beispiel so so eine Erwähnungskette oder sowas äh äh bedeuten würde, ne
so, deswegen, also kann sein, dass mal jemand jetzt quasi für Lokbuchnetzpolitik was gespendet hat, was äh in der Meterebene ein äh
wurde so aber dann nicht dazu geführt hat, dass du das.
Und dann hat der Tim sich ihren neusten Apple Swag geholt und ich habe, ja, das ist stimmt das mit dem Erwähnen ist, ist eine Sache, also ich erwähne ähm.
Besondere Momente.
Nahmen, die es schaffen, zu mir durchzudringen. Der Meterebene dringt nicht zu mir durch, Fletter ist zu zu viele Pseudonyme.
Kann man eh weiß man eh nicht wer es ist genau.
Das ist so der.
Ist schwierig, aber wir werden es vielleicht neu aufdröseln. Wir werden vielleicht einen neuen ähm Modus finden, weiß nicht.
Wir haben uns also was wir überlegen ist äh.
Für diejenigen, die das, äh, die uns unterstützen wollen, die vor allem diese Sendung spezifisch unterstützen wollen und sagen, ey, ich möchte ähm also im Moment gibt es, ich unterstütze Metaebene oder ich unterstütze Linus,
beides ist irgendwie auf eine Weise bildet glaube ich nicht richtig die Sendung ab und wir über werden irgendwie eine Möglichkeit schaffen zu sagen,
für euch, ich unterstütze LN.
LNP geno.
LMP und dann werden diesen Topf, der da vielleicht entsteht, äh den werden Tim und ich dann ähm entsprechend,
in irgendeiner Form verwenden. Dann werden wir uns überlegen, äh wie wir äh einfach entstehende Kosten vielleicht daraus
mal abbilden und gucken es wäre auf jeden Fall sicherlich nicht fair zu sagen wir machen fünfzig fünfzig ne? Weil Tim muss ja hier erstmal die ganze Miete zahlen ähm und dann werden wir irgendwie uns dann mal gucken was da überhaupt ob da überhaupt
also was da überhaupt entstehen kann. Und dann gucken wir mal, was wir damit machen,
das wäre so der Gedanke. Es ist einfach so, ich bin auch ein bisschen unabhängiger, was äh.
Verpflichtungen und Fixkosten angeht als äh der Tim und äh.
Ganz so viele Kinder.
Noch nicht, gell? Ich habe immer aufgepasst.
Äh tja.
Die, das werden wir irgendwann mal machen,
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas zu dem Thema? Meine Güte haben wir jetzt hier lange selbstreferenzielle äh Gelaber, aber zum Glück kann man das ja skippen.
Genau. So, was haben wir denn mit unmittelbarem netzpolitischen Bezug? Ja.
Ja, wir haben äh erstmal noch Feedback zu ähm wir haben ja sehr äh eigentlich nur kurz dieses Thema aufgegriffen ähm mit der,
Ermordung von einer Journalistin oder einer Bloggerin,
wie sie ja dann auch teilweise bezeichnet wurde auf Malta. Und da haben wir einen Kommentar,
wo ich jetzt nur einen Auszug daraus vorlese. Die Autobombe weist auf die Cosa Nostra hin oder jemand will es der Cosanostra in die Schuhe schieben,
Ich war damals bei der zweiten Bombe gegen Paolo, Borcelino in Malta. Die Amtssprache ist zwar Englisch, aber im TV läuft nur italienisch und italienisch, wird immer mehr zu zweiten Ansprache.
Habe deshalb damals das zweite Attentat
durch mein Aufenthalt praktisch hautnah mitbekommen. Das war ein sehr intensives Erlebnis wie Mafia und Antimafia-Anhänger aufeinanderprallen. Diese Wiederholung des alten Musters zeigt auch, dass all die Beteuerungen der Staat finde diesmal wirklich etwas gegen die Mafia tun, nur Beteuerungen wahren. Da hat wieder jemand ein Zeichen gesetzt,
wie man eigentlich dachte, äh es nicht mehr möglich wäre, beziehungsweise äh.
Es einen Deal gäbe, dass die Mafia sich jetzt zurückhalten würde. Das galt aber offensichtlich nicht für die kleine Bloggerin,
und wirft auch ein sehr schlechtes Licht auf die Regierung. Malta war allerdings schon immer Shady Business, nicht nur Rentnerinsel. Die pathesische Billigflotte ähnlich wie Panama oder Liberia gibt es schon lange, da noch ein bisschen,
Hintergrund zu, weil wir das nur politisch äh gesehen haben oder nur auf dieser politischen Ebene gesehen haben, äh dass es ja auch noch im,
so etwas gibt wie die Mafia.
Genau, der erwähnte Paolo Borcelino war so auch einer dieser italienischen Mafia-Jäger, die dann irgendwann an ihrer Tätigkeit sozusagen gestorben sind.
Krasser Scheiß. Ich hatte ja vor langer, langer Zeit mal ein Buch drüber gelesen. Ähm,
Über diese Mafia-Strukturen, wie das Buch war einfach irgendwann nicht mehr ähm.
Also jetzt konntest du einfach irgendwann nicht mehr lesen, weil der rote Faden war einfach so klar, dann kam dieser Staatsanwalt und sagte im Fernsehen, dass er
gegen die Mafia vorgehen würde äh als nächstes fand er ein Schafskopf vor seinem Haustür und hat dann die Ermittlungen nicht eingestellt und dann wurde einfach die komplette Autobahnbrücke gesprengt, über die er gerade fuhr. Äh wie so und das geht in einfach in einem durch, ne? Das ist eine
Alter, das ist so eine das ist echt eine Assibande, muss man so sagen.
Ja
Aber wir haben äh wir haben eine gute Nachricht. Wir haben eine gute Nachricht und wer hätte das gedacht? Ähm.
Erstmalig hier in Lokbuch Netzpolitik thematisiert, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf, noch bevor es von den Medien groß aufgegriffen wurde.
Das haben wir, da waren wir mit die Ersten, ähm die äh dieses Thema behandelt haben. Und zwar aber das wurde dann auch
kurz danach in den weiteren Medien aufgenommen. Es war auch ähm eine also es war quasi so ein bisschen strategisch, dass das anfangs noch nicht in den großen Medien war. Also es war quasi so.
Jetzt solltest du mal sagen, worüber wir eigentlich reden.
Es geht um die ähm
Jetzt hätte ich Entführung gesagt, ja doch die politisch motivierte Gefangennahme von äh Peter Steudtner und
weiteren Menschenrechtsaktivisten in der Türkei, von denen natürlich bei uns in Deutschland insbesondere
Der Name Peter Stoldner äh betont wird.
Der halt der Deutsche.
Weil dort ähm und.
Interessanter, also es war eine große Überraschung. Nach dreizehn Stunden Verhandlung in dem Saal. Es gab ja dann plötzlich eine Anklageschrift. Dann wurde also, da gab's einen Gerichtstermin. Und jetzt forderte die Staatsanwaltschaft auf einmal die Freilassung fast aller Angeklagten.
Ähm und der Richter geht sogar noch dadrüber hinaus und lässt,
Alle frei bis auf den türkischen Amnesty Vorstand Tana Killic. Ähm der äh der weiter, also festgehalten wird und der vor allem zwei Verfahren gegen sich hatte. Ja?
Also nach dem Motto wir schaffen jetzt mal Ruhe, weil irgendwie der diplomatische Druck äh so groß geworden ist
den Leuten, die aus dem Ausland kommen, deshalb haben wir jetzt unser Ziel erreicht und alle haben jetzt wieder ein bisschen Angst und kommen jetzt vielleicht erstmal gar nicht hierher, äh aber so die türkischen, können wir nirgendswo hinschicken, also,
nehmen wir die weiter durch die Mangel äh guckt uns keiner dazwischen.
Genau, das sind das, das ist sind unsere hier. Die machen wir.
Selber kaputt.
So und jetzt kommt aber das Krasse,
Also wird Peter Stoldner dann irgendwie, ne? Hatte etwas über hundert Tage glaube ich in Haft in dem Gefängnis von Selivri,
Kann denn da nochmal hinpackt seine Sachen kommt nach Deutschland, ist äh froh und ähm meidet seither auch äh die Öffentlichkeit, denn ähm das Verfahren ist ja auch noch nicht wirklich,
geschlossen,
Der durfte nur schon mal gehen, seine Untersuchungshaft wurde aufgelöst. Ähm also da ist noch nicht durch und man kann, also ist auch klar, dass der jetzt erstmal seine Ruhe haben will, ja. Ähm aber man fragt sich natürlich, wie kam es dazu?
Und,
das Krasse ist, irgendwie drei Tage später oder so kommt die Story raus, dass Gerhard Schröder äh da als äh sogenannter Backchannel ähm seinen alten Kumpel äh Erdogan,
mal mit dem vermittelt hat und die im Prinzip gesagt haben, na ja guck mal, das irgendwie so diese Kommunikation zwischen Deutschland und der Türkei die eskaliert ja irgendwie so ein bisschen und dann kommt Freund Gerhard, ne? Mann,
Alter Mann, der ja sowieso mit äh den ganzen anderen richtigen Männerherrschern so Putin und so gute Beziehungen hat so, ne
und dann äh ist ist unser guter alter Gerhard Schröder, Halbmarkt zum Erdogan gefahren und hat dann ähm offenbar da mal.
Klar Tisch gemacht.
Klar Tisch gemacht äh und die Eskalation äh dann da irgendwie beigelegt. Jetzt können wir hoffen, dass äh dass wir den Dennis Hückschel irgendwann auch nochmal zurückbekommen.
Das könnte schwierig bleiben.
Das wird äh wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so einfach sein, aber echt einfach mal äh eine schöne Nachricht ist immer.
Eine schöne Nachricht, wenn Menschen, die irgendwie nichts Verbotenes getan haben aus den Fängen einer Diktatur befreit werden.
Tun man langsam verbieten sollte, ja. Ja.
Aber dieses diese Schröder Story fand ich irgendwie so wha.
Fandst du das jetzt besonders überraschend.
Nee, aber es war so komisch, dass du irgendwie so Gerhard Schröder war die ganze Zeit nur mit, also der war, muss man jetzt auch in dem Kontext sehen, ne? Gerhard Schröder hat gerade wieder irgend so einen komischen Posten in Russland angenommen,
dann wurde gerade irgendwie äh zu der Zeit, wo der in die Türkei geflogen ist, war gerade hier irgendwie Feuer äh Doris Schröder-Köpf, sagt ihm, sagt der Bunden, dass äh Gerhard Schröder eine neue Freundin hat,
ist ja auch so ein so ein Serienheirater da, der fünfmal geheiratet oder so ähnlich wie Joschka Fischer, es waren beides so.
Ist ja okay, können wir ja machen, ne?
Standen einfach auf so die Zeremonie, weißt du.
Verliebt sich einfach gern.
Ist einfach, der trägt viel Liebe in sich, ne? Und ähm die die äh das das war halt irgendwie und in in genau in dieser Zeit setzt er sich seelenruhig im Flugzeug
Und macht mal eben so eine dann doch höchst höchst diplomatische äh Unterhändler Sache klar,
Und geht danach irgendwie zu Merkel und sagt hier,
Angela Merkel, ich hab das mal, äh, ich hab das mal so und so grade geklärt und wenn man sich jetzt daran erinnert, was jetzt auch das Verhältnis zwischen Gerhard Schröder und Angela Merkel ist,
ist das halt einfach eine richtig geile Story so. Ich weiß nicht, ob der sich bei Erdogan auch so ausgeführt hat wie in der Elefantenrunde so. Niemand hat die Möglichkeit hier jemanden frei.
Leicht Matrosen.
Meinen sie doch nicht ernsthaft, dass meine Partei diesen Peter Steudner zurückhaben will.
Ja, also geil, äh fand ich irgendwie äh.
Ja, aber da hat man mal wieder gesehen, wie so Politik auch teilweise äh gemacht wird, ja? Das ist ähm,
Damit will ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist der richtige oder einzige oder gar äh wünschenswerte Weg, nur das auch so Teil der Realität, andererseits,
darf man, glaube ich, auch nicht glauben, dass es nicht auch Kanäle gibt, wo Angela Merkel mit ihren äh Kontak,
sehr viel besseren Durchgriff hat als äh Gerhard Schröder, aber wenn's so in diesem Putinkomplex äh reingeht und da sind wir nun mal mit der Türkei halt auch,
ja hat er da wahrscheinlich mehr mehr mehr Bro Power am Start, mit der man da irgendwie was erreichen kann. So schlimm das ist.
Einfach äh ja skurril.
Es erinnert mich so ein bisschen, ich ich weiß nicht genau, wieso die die beiden Storys haben überhaupt gar keine ähm
nicht wirklich parallel, aber es erinnert mich so wie das äh Jean Pen,
Im WL Chapo interviewt hat und danach den der irgendwie drei Tage später gefangen genommen wurde, ne? Wo wo sicher jetzt auch die ähm,
die äh Verschwörungstheorien nähren, dass Trump Pendler im Auftrag des CIA irgendwie dann doch vielleicht ein Handy in der Tasche hatte, damit die
ihn orten können und dadurch dann irgendwie El Chapo gefischt wird. Hat irgendwie überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun, aber es war irgendwie auch so, dass du sechst so what,
schon pennen, was hat der? Warum ist der da auf einmal, ne? Und das ist genauso wie Kert Schröder.
Das ist glaube ich auch nicht das erste Mal, dass Gerd Schröder solche äh Sachen macht oder ist Mist, eine der wenigen, wo es bekannt geworden.
Das ist diplomatie und dass äh ich meine, wir können alle froh sein, dass das Geschehen ist und ähm,
Ich fand's nun mal, vielleicht ist es einer der wenigen Momente, in denen ähm.
Die Tatsache, dass so etwas passiert, auch mal öffentlich mit so viel Aufmerksamkeit versehen wird, ja. Ähm es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn regelmäßig man sich natürlich äh in den diplomatischen
Beziehung ähm darum bemüht einen,
einen freundlichen Kanal zu finden. Darum geht's ja in Diplomatie. Diplomatie ist ja.
Und es ist auch oft die Erklärung, dass andere politische Vorgänge, die man irgendwie so als No-Brainer betrachtet, nicht vorangehen,
weil so viele kleine Deals parallel mit irgendwie gibst du mir, gebe ich dir äh Kaskaden äh existieren, von dem man,
Selbstverständlich oder zumindest nachvollziehbarer Weise so im Detail nichts erfährt, sodass eben einfach bestimmte Maßnahmen nicht möglich sind, selbst wenn sie von einer Mehrheit auf einmal politisch gewollt äh sind oder sie zumindest als Geboten ansieht, dass man da mal
was anschiebt so.
Sehen wir ja auch zum Beispiel in den USA, ne? Diplomatische Beziehungen zu anderen Ländern ähm.
Da werden andere Wege ge.
Da werden andere Wege gesucht. Ähm ich.
Da äh dass man da mal einen Backchannel etabliert und so, ne? Oder mal ein paar Schiffe zusammen kauft halt. Ähm wie wir jetzt gerade in den Paradise-Papers lesen. In den USA äh jetzt äh erste Verhaftungen,
Bereich koludischen US Russia.
Ähm Bob Manafort, Rick Gates und dieser Pappel-Dopulis. Ich weiß, wie es der Vorname von dem nochmal.
George glaube ich. Mhm.
George Fapadovas äh wurden jetzt verhaftet. Ähm da greift also jetzt der äh FBI äh Special Council,
Bob Maler, heißt sie.
Ja, Robot, ja.
Maler Bobmaler, äh greift da jetzt durch und hat jetzt eben ein paar Leute äh.
Angeklagt mit äh mit einer Reihe an äh Vorwürfen, äh die noch nicht mal alle unbedingt mit diesen Colution äh with Russia zu tun haben, ähm aber eben sehr schmerzhafte Druckpunkte sind.
Gerade weil sie nicht damit zu tun.
Gerade weil sie nicht damit zu.
Um die Möglichkeit zu umgehen, dass Trump jetzt einfach mal von seinen Begnadigungsrecht Gebrauch macht, weil das gibt es zwar, aber das greift halt nicht bei allen
Fällen und schon gar nicht bei solchen äh Fiskel äh also diese
Steuervermeidungs äh Geschichte und so weiter. Da hat er halt keine Möglichkeit und er arbeitet ja auch sehr eng mit diesen
Investigators von der äh amerikanischen Steuerbehörde dieser AS zusammen. Das sind wohl so richtige Füchse, also das sind so,
wohin und man auch hört, so äh die Einschätzung ist, so, wenn du wenn du Leute äh finden willst, mit denen du mal wirklich den Schmutz, den den bekommst sozusagen,
dann dann gehst du halt äh dahin und äh ich glaube, das ist auch eine Ansage an dieses ganze Trump-Regime
nach dem Motto wir fangen jetzt an richtig tief zu graben und wir uns ist nichts heilig und,
egal was ihr in den letzten zwanzig Jahren ausgegraben hat, was alles auch nur irgendwie halbwegs justizibel ist.
Das ist ja irgendwie dann fangen sie jetzt bei Fox News ja schon an, denen irgendwie als als Vaterlandslosen Gesellen zu diskreditieren und das ist halt der also der Typ ist halt irgendwie so,
ähm einfach mal weiß ich nicht irgendwie bitteran, dann irgendwie.
Jahrelanger FBI-Chef, Republikaner.
Direktor niemand war länger, genau tief tiefster Republikaner. Das ist einfach mal so eine gute Wahl für diesen Special Investigator. Einfach mal so ein wirklich ich sage jetzt mal äh.
Seriösen und.
Seriöser, höchst anerkannter und hoch für dieses Land und seine Politik äh hochverdienter Mensch,
Hochdekorierter über jeden Zweifel erhabener,
Mensch und man kann jetzt nur hoffen, dass er äh dass er da auch was findet, weil ich äh hoffe ja, dass äh dass wir diesen Trump irgendwie loswerden. Ähm.
Ja, sie haben ja auch schon eine Menge gefunden. Also ist ja bisher nicht alles nur Verdacht und äh ist ja auch noch so ein interessantes Detail,
Zwei haben sie angekündigt, angeklagt, ne? Die sind Paul Manafort und.
Pepper Doppelus, haben sie.
Wie heißt der andere nochmal gleich.
Genau, Rick Gates, weil die haben nichts eingestanden,
ritte, kleine Fisch so. Der musste schon oder hat zumindest zugestanden.
Besser gelogen hat.
Dass er gelogen hat, so. Mit anderen Worten, der hat auch, wie man so schön sagt, gesungen. Und äh,
man weiß jetzt noch nicht mal,
ob er nicht vielleicht auch schon irgendwie seit dem äh ein paar Monaten irgendwie mit dem Mikrofon unter der Krawatte durch die Gegend gelaufen ist. Dementsprechend weiß derzeit keiner von diesen ganzen korrupten Nasen,
was die anderen jetzt schon wissen, werden aber jetzt alle einer nach dem anderen befragt, so und wissen genau, dass sie jetzt irgendwie, wenn sie irgendwo nein sagen,
genauso in der Scheiße stehen können, äh als wenn sie ja sagen und dementsprechend
kriegt das Ganze auf einmal eine ganz interessante Dynamik. Ob das jetzt schon die Dynamik ist, die die Sache äh ans Ende bringt. Ich fand die eine Formulierung ganz schön, also jemand fragte so, ist das äh
nee, aber jetzt. So. Ja, also jetzt geht's los.
Dass wir klassische Prisonas Dilemma, ne? Also am am Ende wäre es für alle besser, wenn sie einfach nur nix sagen,
Aber sie wissen immer, man weiß nicht, ob und was der andere gesagt hat und wenn du einmal äh quasi verbrieft sagen kannst, hier, der hat gesungen. So, dann äh.
Bricht alles auseinand.
Bricht halt alles auseinander und ähm das das wird jetzt da gespielt werden, da können wir gespannt weiterschauen. Interessant finde ich aber auch, dass
dieses Narrativ, das der äh Peppedorpol ist da ein kleiner Fisch ist, das zieht sich irgendwie durch. Das haben sie zum Beispiel schon etabliert
kommt, ne? Das war ja dann irgendwie immer so äh als die als erstes mal auf denen angesprochen wurden, haben ja irgendwie alle schon gesi,
Wir wissen nicht, wer das ist, der hat keine offizielle Position bei uns gehabt, das war ein kostenfreier Helfer, wir waren nicht zufrieden mit seiner Performance und so, der will sich nur wichtig machen, ja? Ähm so ein äh so ein,
Kleiner Fisch kann das nicht gewesen sein, wenn die Russen sich ausgerechnet den ausgesucht haben.
Ja, deshalb ist ja auch vor dem Paul Manufakt gesagt, der immerhin diese Trump Compaine irgendwie mehr mehrere Monate angeleitet hat. Der war der Chef und so, ja, das war ja nur vorübergehend und.
Oh je, also das da äh da gibt's jetzt wieder Hoffnungen, das ist auf jeden Fall ein echt geiler Krimi, der sich da jetzt entfaltet, ne? Also das, das hat echt das Zeug ähm,
so zum zum Blogbuster irgendwie äh bin ich mal sehr gespannt äh wie sich das jetzt da noch weiterentwickelt,
Amtsenthebungsverfahren ist da aber ohnehin nochmal eine ganz äh schwierige Sache. Also ich halte das für irgendwie nach wie vor unwahrscheinlich, dass am Ende irgendwie jemand hingeht und sagt, jo, hier, ich bin Kronzeuge, Trump,
hat das und das gesagt, ist damit einhundert Prozent über alle Zweifel schuldig,
eine Verschwörung mit dem Feind eingegangen zu sein und damit ist er jetzt auch ist es jetzt einfach ist er einfach vollständig untragbar. Ähm.
Es gibt ja sogar interessanterweise, also um das mal so in in eine Perspektive zu setzen, das mit diesem
den Begriff des Opposition Research, ja? Ähm! Wo einer der das, der da sehr der überraschend da sehr starke Stellung bezieht ist hier Jeremy Skay von von die Intersept,
Äh dem ja auch so ein Podcast Intersepted. Wo er so sagt so, ähm.
Die äh die Demokraten haben sich doch auch Aufzeichnungen von Donald Trumps volgär,
Sexismus äh zuspielen lassen. Die mussten die auch irgendwo her organisieren. Da hat auch äh da hat auch niemand gefragt, wo sie die herhaben, ne? Man sucht sich Dreck über den Gegner und äh das ist äh das gute Recht,
eines jeden,
also sagt so selbst wenn jetzt irgendwie rauskommt, dass dieser Peppedorpolus sich dafür interessiert hat und äh so, dass das noch lange nicht irgendwie äh so ein glasklarer, strafbarer Akt
wäre. Glasklarer, strafbarer Akt wäre, wenn der Trump gesagt hätte, holt mir mehr E-Mails. Stellt sich raus, hat er
Der hat ja im Fernsehen schon, bevor der überhaupt gewählt wurde, gesagt, Russia, ivan Find, äh, Remaining, für die E-Mails, also der ist halt irgendwie gegen 'ne ganze Menge ähm fürchterliche Immun,
Spannend wird ähm glaube ich eher dieses Obstruction of Justicing mit der mit dem Absetzen von Comi. Aber es ist, ist echt,
'ne zitternde Angelegenheit und was hatte.
Und man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass Brotmüller mittlerweile halt Zugriff auf seine Textreturns hat. Also da sind sie ja auch dran. Also ich habe,
dass sie sein komplettes Imperium jetzt auseinander nehmen. Einschließlich seiner Tochter, seiner zahlreichen Söhne und Schwiegersöhne et cetera. Die werden
alle jetzt einmal komplett von vorne bis hinten durchgeleuchtet. Jetzt kommen noch diese
Paradise, Papers, die du schon erwähnt hast dazu, das ist ja jetzt gerade Breaking News, ne? Wir erinnern uns, diese Panama Papers, das war so die erste äh äh Linie eigentlich, das heißt dort kamen halt zahlreiche Dokumente von diesen
in Panama basierten äh Agenturnamen jetzt vergessen äh wo halt alle möglichen,
führenden Politiker, Businessleute et cetera, offenbar halt Unternehmung haben, die,
Dort Geld gewaschen haben und ähm.
Also diese ganze Geldwäscherei, aber was ich da auch sehe, ist, du hast ja äh schon angekündigt, äh äh schon auch auf die Panamer Papers Bezug genommen und da ist jetzt sind da so viele gefallen.
Gefallen nicht, aber haben drin gestanden und jetzt ist ja unter anderem dieser Handelsminister
äh ähm von äh Trump dieser Ross Wilber Ross auch erwähnt, dass er eine der ersten Sachen, die sie jetzt aus
gegraben haben, man kann davon ausgehen, dass wir in den nächsten Wochen ja noch eine ganze Kanonade weiterer Kenntnisse kommt, o,
die dann Folgen haben, ist eine ganz andere Frage, ne? Das äh merkt man, das braucht schon eine sehr große Springflut, um da diese Mauern einzureißen, weil wir reden jetzt hier quasi um die das, das sind die Systeme, mit der sich
Leute, die zu reich sind, äh quasi von Gesetzeslagen,
freihalten, ne? Und das, da kannst du noch so gute Gesetze haben über diese Kanäle.
Finden einfach Transfers äh statt, dort wird irgendwie Geld geparkt und in Sicherheit gebracht. Äh was wahrscheinlich global, einfach,
Die globale Korruption als solche mehr oder weniger ermöglicht.
Das ist.
Das ist das genau.
Ist das Form. Das ist das ist die.
Das sind die Asozialen. Das sind die, die die Regeln nicht für sich gelten lassen, das sind die großen Fische, die äh sage ich mal hier ein äh Zusammenleben,
in in einer Gesellschaft prägen oder zelebrieren und das selber diese Regeln für sich nicht anerkennen. Wie einfach selber,
sowas einfaches wie Steuern hinterziehen, das zu, also Leute, da ist die ganze Ungerechtigkeit der Welt, ist in in diesen Vorgängen,
ähm so etwas wie Steuerhinterziehung ist nicht billig.
Musst du dir erstmal leisten können. Und genau deswegen.
Machen es auch nur Reiche. Und genau deswegen trifft es äh dann eben die Armen, ja? Es gibt diesen schönen Spruch arm sein, kannst du dir eigentlich nicht leisten,
ist zu teuer, weil du, weil du für alles Zinsen bezahlen musst, äh weil du äh weil du, wenn du mehr Geld verdienst, äh was weiß ich, höhere Steuern bezahlen musst, ja. Und da ist, da ist.
Und kein Bailout, wenn du keine Kohle mehr hast.
Genau, also ne, alles die Benachteiligung der armen und armen würde ich hier bis weit in die Mittelklasse mit hochziehen. Ähm findet genau hier statt,
Und das ist das, worüber gegen sich diese gesamten Trump-Wähler,
gerichtet haben ohne in der Lage zu sein das zu artikulieren. Ich erinnere mich übrigens ist jetzt auch ziemlich genau ein Jahr her, dass der Typ gewählt wurde, ne? Ähm.
Wo ich hier in der Sendung auch gesagt habe, dass die Menschen, die den gewählt haben.
Bei allem, was sie wollen, was sie, was sie äh politisch erreichen wollen, wie sie sich nicht wahrgenommen fühlen, wie sie sich von der Gesellschaft verarscht fühlen,
Das sind alles sogar legitim ist, aber dass sie den absoluten Bock zum Gärtner gerade machen, ja? Und dass äh dass es egal, selbst wenn alle ihre Anliegen äh korrekt sind und richtig sind, dass sie hier den falschen gewählt haben,
Nämlich jemanden, der das alles nur noch viel, viel schlimmer macht, in der für alles, was sie hasst, äh äh steht. Und das fressen die äh den problemlos aus der Hand, ja?
Seit seit Monaten wird ja immer wieder dieser eine wunderschöne äh retweetet, wo dann so die Schafe auf der Wiese stehen und da ist da so ein großes Plakat mit dem Wolf, der sagt,
I will edu und die Schafe so Hitels it like it is,
Ja
Und das äh haben wir ja hier äh Gott sei Dank nicht mit derselben Durchschlagskraft mit der AfD im Prinzip genau dasselbe Spielchen so. Und jetzt sieht man ja auch, dass sie sich da auch äh schön mit Facebook äh versucht haben, einzulassen,
ist auch gleich nochmal äh besprechen. Also vielleicht um dieses Trampkapitel mal abzuschließen oder gab's noch einen Aspekt, den du äh.
Nee, ich äh wollte da nur meine neue neue Season, meine Begeisterung, ja.
Ja, ja, das ist äh für alle und da haben wir was auch was gemeinsam, ne? Du bist ja auch so ein bisschen auf so einem auf diesem ähm,
ist ja so quasi die Fernsehserie, die man jetzt grade guckt, ist so Trump, ne?
Dieser Trump macht mich fertig. Ich es ist.
Ich habe ja ich glaube wer hier seit einiger Zeit zuhört, weiß, dass ich eine Kritik am politischen Betrieb habe, ja. Ähm.
Aber das spielt sich auf einer ganz ander.
Aber das ist das spielt sich auf einer inhaltlichen Ebene ab. So, ich, also ich für mich ist nicht, für mich ist wirklich katastrophal. Ich.
Beruflich setze mich ja mit Security auseinander, ja? Ich muss mir ja darüber Gedanken machen, dass ein System auf eine Weise resilient ist, äh so und so denke ich auch über diese
über diese Situation danach, dass ich feststelle, dass es da dieses schöne, wunderschöne, politische äh System gibt, nicht perfekt, aber irgendwie
halbwegs ähm.
Checks and Balances.
Harzer seine Checks and Balaces hat mal echt jemand sich drüber nach äh Gedanken gemacht und es war immerhin mal ein paar Jahrzehnte tragfähig und ähm das hat auch noch den schlimmsten äh äh ausgehalten. Ja, aber,
dass das, dass dieser Donald Trump es ernsthaft geschafft hat, das ist einfach ne und dann dann kriege ich wieder böses Feedback, wenn ich jetzt sage, dass die Leute so blöd sind, das war mir einfach, das hat einfach keine auf dem Schirm gehabt. Und,
Es ist halt leider nicht mit intelligent intelligenter Kalkulation zu erklären. Donald Trump zu wählen. Das ist eine Louise Canon und das ist eine äh mich macht das wirklich äh mich nimmt das echt mit,
Zu sehen, was dass ich mir jedes Mal denke, so äh genau das ist das, was ich mir eigentlich denke.
Ja, es ist äh unfassbar, also äh
hilft natürlich aus auch wieder das Ganze so sportlich zu nehmen und jetzt nutzt man das halt eben um und dann schaut man sich jetzt sozusagen diese neue Fernsehserie an
Der Aufstieg und Fall des Donald Trump so, Aufstieg hatten wir jetzt schon durch, kommen wir zum Fall, ja? So und der wird kommen.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Ja irgendwann, vielleicht.
Der wird irgendwann kommen, ich sage nicht, der kommt nächste Woche oder so oder am Ende dieses Jahres ist es durch so. Michael Moor meinte ja noch im ersten Jahr, mal gucken, das äh sehe.
Das hat sie jetzt nicht bewahrt. Ach so und erste Herr sei nach innen Orgeration, ja. Mhm.
Ist ja noch nicht durch, das erste Jahr, aber.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Es hat halt interessante Effekte und da ich ja immer optimist bin, ne? Äh.
Ich bin halt sehr gespannt, was es auch sozusagen für Wunden schließende äh Effekte hat auf die amerikanische Gesellschaft. Also es gibt ja schon so ein paar Effekte, ne. Viel mehr Frauen.
Lassen sich jetzt gerade zur Wahl aufstellen, als jemals zuvor, ja? Ich denke, dass auch viele,
Aktivisten oder auch vor allem auch normale Bürger gemerkt haben. Oh Scheiße, wenn ich mich so raushalte aus allem, dann dann,
Ist das nicht nur so ein, so eine Warnung, dass äh hier alles den Bach runtergeht, dann geht's den Bach runter,
Das ist ja ein reales Gefühl für eine, für die aufgeklärte Minderheit. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Wenn alle Leute, die halbwegs gripselne Birne haben, auch einfach gewählt hätten, wäre das gar nicht passiert.
Ja und also es wird ja viel gelobt, so Art Trump war unglaublich gut für den Aktivismus, ja.
Ich würde die die Kehrseite davon ist, ja schön, so ist super, die Leute lernen wieder ein bisschen sich zusammenzureißen äh gemeinsam äh dass sie an den Sachen dranbleiben müssen, sie lernen, machen sich darüber Gedanken, wie
politische Strukturen funktionieren, sie machen sich darüber Gedanken, wie strategisch politische Kämpfe geführt werden müssen und so weiter. Die hinterfragen auch sehr viel, man muss ja auch sagen
Donald Trump, das Phänomen Donald Trump wird ja auch von einer wahnsinnig guten ähm Medienlandschaft,
begleitet. Ja, also was wir da sehen an Investigativ äh Journalismus, was wir da sehen an
allein hier diese politischen Abendsendungen, ne? John Oliver und Traver Noah und so die die sitzieren das so.
Stephen Kult Beers.
So großartig, so so genau das ist wirklich also es ist wirklich ganz toll, aber uns muss irgendwie auch klar sein,
Ich zum Beispiel, ich will gar kein Aktivist sein, ich bin eigentlich auf diesem Planeten gekommen, um irgendwie in Ruhe zu leben und ich werde am laufenden Band daran gehindert und muss mich mit so einer Scheiße auseinandersetzen. Ich fände das super
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich das alles nicht machen müsste, weil das hieße, dass die Welt insgesamt einfach mal in Ordnung ist und ich nicht irgendwie ähm äh gezwungen wäre,
mich da andauernd einzubringen und zu sagen, Kinder reißt euch doch mal zusammen. So, ne, ich kette, ich könnte mir das auch ohne vorstellen. Ich muss nicht bis ans Lebensende Aktivist sein.
Genau, das ist der eigentliche Skandal, ne?
Würde mich gerne in ein paar Jahren zur Ruhe setzen und sagen, so, ist alles gut jetzt. Ich hab hal.
Wat in ein paar Jahren schon. Was war soll ich denn dann machen.
Die machen wir, dann sitzen wir äh dann was anderes, die Welt ist in Ordnung, Tim, was macht man, wenn die in Ordnung ist? Ich meine, dir wird schon irgendwas einfallen, was du noch verbessern kannst, aber.
Irgendwas.
Nein, aber so dieses Polit, ne? Also ich fänd das nicht schlimm, äh also das das Ziel wäre natürlich eine Welt, in der man diesen Aktivismus nicht braucht,
sage ich mal, ne? Ähm natürlich ist es trotzdem gut, wenn man weiß, wie man den macht und wenn man äh die Strukturen äh und die Kanäle ähm und die Bewegungs äh Möglichkeiten und die Vernetzung hat, den aufrechtzuerhalten,
Aber ich hätte jetzt auch kein Problem damit ähm äh einfach nur zu sagen, morgens aufzustehen und zu sagen, ja, ist eigentlich Welt ist okay.
Ja gut, aber ist sie ist sie nicht, ist sie nicht und insbesondere in USA nicht, auch wenn sie da trotzdem alle Netflix gucken? Äh auch wenn ihre Lieblingsserie jetzt, also so als äh als Präsident im Fernsehen, da wird's ja auch schneller gekranzelt als äh richtiger Präsident.
Ja, das.
Das, das ist nämlich auch noch so ein Punkt, ich bin mal gespannt, wir werden eine eine Prognose wage ich. Der Abschied,
Also wenn Donald Trump ausscheidet, was ich nicht unbedingt glaube, ja, aber wenn das passiert, dann wird es.
Bittersuite. Und zwar der wird am Ende für etwas gehen, was weh tut. Zum Beispiel.
Vielleicht ist er schwul. Ruck zuck wäre der da weg. Also na ich nehme jetzt ein ein hypothetisches Beispiel und das wäre jetzt so etwas wie,
Das wäre jetzt äh bittersuite, ja? Donald Trump äh Sexskandal, schwul äh nicht zu tragen. Ähm,
Wir wollen keinen schwulen Weg, ne? Und das wäre halt
Bitter Sweet, weil dann wüsstest du, dass er, dass er für das für das absolut falsche geht und dass du da sitzen musst und sagst so, Alter, komm, jetzt halt einmal die Fresse, der geht, ja. Und dann müssten wir am Ende noch irgendwie ähm,
sage ich mal, äh sagen, wir wollen nicht, dass er geht für Homosexualität, wer ist ein gutes Recht, Homosexuelle zu sein. Nehme ich mal das meine ich so mit Bittersweet? Ja.
Okay, ich äh kann sein am Ende weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch Wurst.
Auf jeden Fall man merkt immerhin, das das darf man ja mal jetzt auch nicht außen vor lassen. So Scheiße der ist,
So tacke auch diese ganzen Republikaner im Kongress und im Senat sind, weil wirklich, also die haben eine eine Auffassung vom Leben, da da fasse ich mir nur an Kopf, ja. Die haben in neun Monaten,
kein einziges Gesetz durchgebracht.
Kein wie sagt man so schön? Major Vegislation.
Im SZ ja kein medial, aber da gibt's im SZ-Magazin, ein äh tolle Zusammenfassung, Till Krause, Charlotte, Hunsika und Roland Schulz haben sich äh angeschaut, was hat der
Trump denn in einem Jahr bewirkt und sind irgendwie natürlich und President, ja? Ähm,
Aber da hat der, der hat.
Auf Ministerebene ist halt sehr viel äh gelaufen, ne? Die Umweltbehörde äh schwächt eigentlich alle Behörden.
Volker Ruhl soll gelockert werden. Das war eine Regulierungsmaßnahme äh gegen den Risiko äh risikoreichen Eigenhandel bei Banken. Äh Reaktionen auf die Finanzkrise zweitausendacht wird jetzt abgeschafft, ja. Ähm,
Trump ließ einen roten Kopf auf sein, einen roten Knopf, auf seinem Schreibtisch im weißen Haus installieren, er dient dazu, eine Coca-Cola zu bestellen. Hat er erreicht,
Anbieter von Telefon und Internetverbindungen können leichter Daten über das Surfverhalten ihrer Nutzer aufzeichnen und verkaufen. Fischer braucht nicht mehr zu beachten, wie viele Delfine oder Meeresschildkröten sie als Beifang in ihren Netzen haben. Klagen von Transsexuellen wegen Benachteiligung sind vor Arbeitsgerichten nicht mehr als sexuelle Diskriminierung zu werten,
als was denn dann? Das Verbot in Nationalparks Wasser in Plastikflaschen zu verkaufen wurde aufgehoben.
Ja gut, aber es ist alles, es ist alles.
Anweisung an Staatsanwälte auch bei kleineren Drogendelikten, die Maximalstrafe zu fordern.
Es ist alles reversibel.
Ja und davon stirbt keiner sofort. Hätten sie irgendwie ihre Health Care Reform durchgebracht, die sogenannte,
oder würden sie jetzt mit dieser Textreform durchkommen, das hätte halt sofort unfassbar weitreichende Auswirkungen gehabt,
auch nicht mal eben in ein paar Jahren wieder so ohne weiteres zurückdrehen lassen. Das ist das, was ich meine,
Also ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel Hoffnung verbreiten, bleibt auf jeden Fall äh spannend mit der äh dummen Socke. In gewisser Hinsicht hat's ja auch äh zumindest der Late Night Comedy äh zu einem Revival Deluxe äh verschafft,
sie besonders schlecht das gucken wir mal eher auch vielleicht mal wirklich auf die Netz.
Ja genau. Kümmern uns mal wieder.
Aspekte dieses ganzen Dings, weil das äh da war jetzt die letzte Woche in der Tat sehr reichhaltig.
Egal, also die US Intelligence Community ist irgendwie zu der zu dem Schluss gekommen, ha, das ist ja wohl bei.
Bei Twitter. Ähm.
Und bei Russia Today irgendwie ähm Bemühungen gab mit äh,
die Wahl in den USA zu beeinflussen und dass dieses auf auf Weisung,
äh der russischen Regierung geschehen ist. Also, dass ähm die russische Regierung ähm,
Aktivitäten.
Angestrengt hat ähm in der US-Wahl für Unruhe zu sorgen, ja und vielleicht dafür zu sorgen, dass ein äh Kandidat gewählt wird oder eine andere Kandidatin nicht.
Und dann gab es äh dazu auch einige äh oder eine oder mehrere Anhörungen vor dem äh Kongress,
wo dann Vertreter von von Facebook und und von Twitter zu den Aktivitäten um die Wahl Stellung nehmen mussten. Und da ähm kamen dann zum Beispiel auch zur,
bei raus, dass ähm ähm Facebook,
nochmal in der Datenbank geschaut hat und gesagt hat, ja es gab irgendwie so pro so russische Anzeigen irgendwie und die haben wir wohl hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen Mal angezeigt. Vorher war die Zahl irgendwie sehr, sehr viel geringer
ja. Ähm.
Und dann gab's irgendwie, dann wurde das aber auch sehr äh sehr skurril, dass Twitter nämlich dann Ende Oktober sagte, ah so übrigens, wir geben hiermit bekannt, äh dass wir,
von von Russia Today keine,
Werbeanzeigen mehr annehmen. Wir verbannen die quasi von unserem Netzwerk. Ja, also wir sagen mit RT werden wir nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten,
und die Reaktion von äh RT darauf war ähm sie haben das,
Sales Pitch, Slide Deck mit dem Twitter vor der Wahl bei ihnen angetreten ist,
veröffentlicht. Weil Twitter ist quasi zu denen hingekommen und hat dann also hat so ein Salespitch-Ding gehabt und hat gesagt, hier kauft äh Twitter Brings, you close hat to what methase most ähm
und dann haben sie irgendwie gezeigt so hier in der US-Wahl, da kannst du irgendwie hier Burnie Sanders und so
und hier sind was wir dir anbieten können, weil wie viel unser Value Ad ist bei einem Budget von anderthalb Millionen, äh kannst du at AT dot com so und so äh pushen und ähm.
Hier geile Zielgruppe voll billig.
Hier ist, genau. Mach doch mal zur Wahl bei uns äh auf Twitter Theater und bezahlt uns.
Poläre Plattform hast, aber du weißt nicht so richtig, wie du es monetarisieren sollst, dann kommst du auf die wildesten Ideen so und dann ist irgendwann die Botschaft eine andere.
Und dann als Beispiel.
Thema heute schon mal.
Ey und als Beispiel sage ich Twitter ja ähm in diesem Slide ein Tweet äh
also große Hillary Clinton zeigen sie da, ne? Und dann zeigen sie einen Tweet, wo jemand sagt,
Huro Deuro have as the president. Retreat for dispotator all like for Hillary. Und dieser Tweet hat irgendwie zweiundzwanzigtausend Redfeeds und zweitausend Likes, ne? Und das ist irgendwie das, womit Twitter
Ähm offenbar zu Kunden gegangen ist und gesagt hat, guck mal, wir haben einen Twitter geil. Man kann äh die Frau mit einer Kartoffel äh vergleichen.
Das war ihr Pitch für RT.
Das war, das ist ein, das ist ein.
Wow, das ist ja krass.
Der andere Tweet, den sie zu der der andere Tweet, den sie,
Der andere Tweet, den sie zu Burnards Burnie Sandard, meine Güte. Der andere Tweet, den sie zu Burnie Sanders hatten, äh war echt ganz den fand ich besser. Ähm,
Voting Trump,
Allso if McDonald's ist out of Chicken Nuggets, halt coin to eat twentyskopions. Den fand ich besser, aber seid auch irgendwie so, ich meine, wenn das irgendwie die Art von politischem Engagement ist, mit dem sie irgendwie,
Offenbar billionen Budgets haben wollen, da müssen wir uns echt auch nicht wundern, wie es uns auf Twitter ergeht, ja?
Und wie äh ich meine, wenn wenn Donald Trump dieses Sales Pitch Slide Deck gesehen hat, dann kann ich mir erklären, warum der so twittert, wie er twittert.
Twitter sieht halt, was irgendwie populär ist und was gut rumgeht und so, ne? Also.
Also das ist äh.
Ganz schön verlogen, ne?
Ja, interessant ist ähm.
Außerdem äh wurden dann so Sachen bekannt wie das ist also hier eine äh Gruppen äh russischer Trolle gab, die zum Beispiel sowas gemacht haben wie ähm,
In ein und derselben Stadt gleichzeitig
zu zwei Demonstrationen aufzurufen und zwar einmal irgendwie für die Freiheitsrechte von Muslimen und einmal sowas hier gegen die Islamisierung des Abendlandes. Und die haben sie einfach beide gleichzeitig stattfinden lassen. Und äh das hat äh haben da halt irgendwie ein paar Werbekampagnen gemacht und haben halt irgendwie so so spontan Versammlungen
stattfinden lassen, ja? Pro und gegen einfach nur ähm letztendlich, um die Zerrissenheit der Gesellschaft ähm,
da da äh dafür ein Kristallisationspunkt zu bieten. Und den ne, das russische Interesse
vorsichtig gesagt in dieser Situation scheint gar nicht unbedingt zu sein dass jetzt Donald Trump oder Hillary Clinton haben, sondern,
Noch viel schöner und wichtiger für die ist, dass die amerikanische Gesellschaft,
gespalten ist und kritisch gegenüber dem äh demokratischen und medialen äh System dieses Landes. Und ähm.
Das hat äh da sehen wir jetzt immer mehr, dass das äh wohl ganz gut ähm auch funktioniert. Ähm unter anderem.
Gibt's da um die Debatte ähm dass Twitter und Facebook ja im Prinzip sagen, wir sind.
Plattformen. Auf uns realisieren sich Dinge,
und das in diesen Anhörungen wird wie wird die Frage eine Rolle spielen und das wird uns die nächsten Jahre auch in Deutschland und regulativ beschäftigen. Was ist das,
Was ist dieses Facebook? Die die haben die besten Anwälte, die sie kriegen könnten mit den besten Jahresgeldern, die sie zahlen könnten, darauf angesetzt zu verhindern, dass Facebook eine Media-Company wird,
weil sie dann natürlich Media Company hat einfach mal schon äh eine Dekade,
ein äh ein Jahrhundert Regulation,
In den USA. Ne, Zeitung, was kannst du schreiben, was kannst du nicht schreiben, Fernsehen, was kannst du machen, kannst du nicht machen. Wer ist verantwortlich, so ähm da gibt's und sobald das greift, sind die in einer Welt aus Schmerz,
wenn,
Und deswegen müssen sie das verhindern, ja? Sie wollen natürlich jede wollen keine Regulation haben, natürlich nicht. Und das ist der Kampf, der sich da jetzt in den USA.
Das Problem, was sich da jetzt entwickeln wird und wo jetzt natürlich auch Leute sagen, ey Freunde, wie kann das denn bitteschön sein, dass ihr dass ihr nach einem Jahr auf einmal merkt, dass ach da gab's diese Kampagnen, die kamen von denen und denen
ein Jahr später fällt uns auf, dass wir die hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen Leuten gezeigt haben. Hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen Leuten Leute hat hier niemand anders erreicht
ähm zu keinem Zeitpunkt in diesem Land, so ungefähr, ne? Und und wenn das jemand getan hat.
Dann unterlag das den der Kontrolle und der Transparenz, die wir zum Beispiel für unsere Fernsehsender haben. Warum ist das, warum gibt's das bei euch nicht,
Das wird also, das wird eine, eine sehr spannende äh Debatte, die sich da jetzt abbildet. Wir werden da noch ein bisschen mehr darüber lernen, wie nun wirklich diese russischen Meinungsroboter,
agiert haben, vor denen wir alle ja so eine große Angst hatten. Und ich denke, da ist jetzt gerade die Musik.
Da und äh ja gab jetzt auch so einen Cenitheering, wo äh Vertreter von Facebook und ich glaube auch von Twitter noch ein paar anderen Plattformen da waren und.
Mein Lieblingssenator äh in den USA, unser allerlieber Lieblingssenator. Ich glaube, du weißt schon, wen ich meine, ne?
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Das ist überhaupt der großartigste Typ überhaupt in den ganzen USA.
Angesagt, der ist mein Lieblingssenator, aber was macht ihn großartig?
Na ja, Elffranken hat ja eine interessante Vorgeschichte. Elf Frank war jahrelang bei Setterday Nightlife, einer der führenden äh Komiker und ist einfach ein unfassbar komischer Typ,
Aber er ist ja auch derjenige, der diese ganzen Cenity-Rings irgendwie im Wesentlichen vorantreibt, der ja auch schon den Jeff Sessions so äh mit seinem Verhör so in die Ecke gebracht hat, dass dass der ja schon sozusagen seine ersten Meineide äh quasi auf den Tisch gelegt hat,
ne? Also äh Elfraken kannst du, kannst du ja mal aufschreiben, äh wenn man aben.
Elf-Franken-Show und so, ja.
Wenn würde man, wenn man Abend, man macht nichts zu tun hast, dann surfst du dich einfach mal durch Elfranken auf YouTube und wirst es nicht bereuen. Wie auch immer. Dann hat er irgendwie diesen Facebook, diesen Facebookanwalt irgendwie gegrillt,
ja? Und äh seine Fragen sind wirklich gut,
gewählt. Also er hat immer eine hervorragende, klare Art und Weise zu fragen, ja, wo dann die Befragten einfach gar nicht mehr können, als sich irgendwie selber ein Bein zu stellen. Und äh,
meinte er auch so ihr habt Millionen von Datenpunkten den ihr irgendwie jeden Tag miteinander kombiniert, um da irgendwie Werbung auszuspielen und zu stimmen was irgendwie relev.
Scheiß Schuh noch zu verkaufen.
Aber ihr schaltet hier irgendwie Wahlwerbung und die wird in Robel bezahlt,
Wahlwerbung Rubel, zwei Datenpunkte so, ja.
Den Ausschnitt habe ich auch gesagt.
Dass ihr das nicht irgendwie mal zusammenbringen könnt und,
Typ Schwitzer und dann so können sie, können sie mir bestätigen, dass ihr das nie wieder tun werdet. Aussage treffen der Typ, ne? Und dann so, ja, das Mindbiest haben, Letterpoint Spree Mist und
Signals wie Mist, ja. Und äh da muss man da auf jeden Fall drüber reden, aber alleine das kann's ja auch nicht sein, wenn man so weiter so und dann legt er noch einen nach mit
Was wäre, wenn er jetzt mit dem nordkoreanischen Wand irgendwie bezahlt würde das dann reichen? Also genau kann man das nicht sehen und
Fantastisch, wie ihr sie einfach alle vor sich hertreibt. Also allein dafür äh.
Für lohnt sich dieses ganze Spektakel schon so unterirdisch das alles auch ist.
Wird auf jeden Fall auch, glaube ich, kann man vorsichtig sagen, ein Thema sein, was ähm vielleicht den den CCC-Kongress auch nochmal beschäftigen wird. Ähm.
Ich habe das ja in der Sendung ja schon öfter mal so angesprochen, dass,
Wir uns da mit diesen sozialen Netzwerken, die da haben wir uns am Ende echt ein sehr äh,
Ei gelegt, was äh für uns nochmal problematisch äh wird oder die Problematik, die Probleme sehen wir ja jetzt hier. Kurz gesagt, diese äh,
Zielgerichtetheit der Werbung, die jetzt eben auch in andere Bereiche, der man Verhaltensmanipulation äh hineinwächst,
da Anklang findet die Machtzentralisierung an zentralen Stellen wo diese Datenbanken eben betrieben werden ähm die.
Das ab.
Bilden von einfach allem, allem öffentlichen Leben und allen politischen Interessen in in dieser Form, das wird uns als Gesellschaft noch äh lange beschäftigen und scheint gerade äh in der Phase zu sein, wo wir jetzt mal so richtig langsam in Richtung der negativen,
Konsequenzen losmarschieren,
Mal schauen, wie viele davon wir noch am eigenen Leib erfahren bis äh vielleicht irgendwann mal kluge Lösungen für das Problem herkommen. Technische gab's ja schon immer.
Kurzmeldung, eine Kurzmeldung mache ich noch. In drei. Ähm das war etwas, was mich sehr überrascht hat. Und zwar ähm.
Kam der Patrick Beuth auf mich zu, der ähm der Journalist,
und sagte hier ich hab hier einen, der behauptet, dass die ganzen irgendwie von den zweihundert beliebtesten IOS Apps irgendwie hundert äh ihre Kommunikation,
nicht verschlüsseln würden.
Also keiner hat die PS.
Kein HTPS haben und dass da auch, dass die auch unverschlüsselt Passwörter übertragen und äh hast du alles nicht gesehen. Kannst du das mal,
verifizieren bitte. Und ich sag, du, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, weil Apple hat ja vor zwei Jahren angekündigt
dass sie das verpflichtend machen und dass sie einfach die APIs nicht mehr, dass sie die Apps nicht mehr zulassen und dass sie dafür eine AP äh eine eigene interne AP gebaut haben, die gar nicht mehr HTTP als ähm,
als als API-Kommunikation zulässt und so weiter und das kann eigentlich gar nicht sein. Und dann ähm habe ich also
da habe ich gesagt, das kann sowas von nicht sein, dass ich mir noch nicht mal die Mühe machen würde, das zu prüften in den letzten Jahren, aber ich mach's jetzt einfach mal und siehe da,
stimmt,
ja? HTTP, ja, irgendwie Account, Creation, User, Neim, Passwort, alles schön frei durch das durch das offene Web mit offenen Standards in in HTTP,
Da war ich dann doch ein bisschen von den Socken. Muss ich echt sagen, hätte ich, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ist in der Tat auch etwas äh erschreckend nach so einem langen Zeitr.
Im langen Zeitraum.
Gab ja schon die Möglichkeit für App Diverlopper äh wenn sie ihr Update einstellen
zu sagen na ja wir verwenden aber noch harte TP, weil aus Gründen Pipapo ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das vielleicht einfach übermäßig,
geduldet wurde, ja, über diesen Weg. Äh es kann natürlich auch sein, dass die Prüfung nicht richtig greift und dass das alles nur äh Gewäsch war, also
da muss man mal schauen wie Apple reagiert hübscherweise, wenn.
Gar nicht reagiert.
Wollte ich grad sagen, werden wahrscheinlich erstmal überhaupt nichts dazu sagen, aber wenn unter Umständen äh unten im App Store Gefüge nochmal nachtreten, wenn da wirklich äh irgendwas schiefgelaufen ist.
Also es gibt heute keinen Grund mehr ähm gerade so eine AP-Kommunikation von einer App nicht mit HTPS zu mach.
Also es gibt keinen guten Grund.
Ja, es gibt keine Aktie, kein, kein Zurist, keinen geltenden Grund. Ähm.
Das Zertifikat kostet dich nichts mehr. Mein ich kann so, guck mal, es gab auch mehrere Stufen, ne? Also einige haben das einfach über HTP gehabt, andere haben die haben die Zertifikate nicht geprüft,
ja? Ähm wie man es machen würde, ist mit äh sagen wir mal Public oder CA Pinning, dass man sagt, ich will ein Zertifikat sehen, was von meiner eigenen CA,
Unterschrieben ist, ich prüfe gar nicht gegen echt oder gegen den Surfstore, den ich hier habe, sondern ich weiß, von welcher CA ich das unterschrieben haben möch.
Was Lino so jetzt sagen möchte ist, dass die Programme sich sozusagen ihre verschlüsselte Kommunikation auch unterschreiben und das überprüfbar ist ja.
Ja äh das wäre das, wie man's macht. Jetzt kann ich sagen, so eigentlich sehe ich noch nicht mal einen Grund, es nicht so zu machen, aber ich würde.
Ich lasse nicht gelten, nicht hatte PS. Man dafür gibt's keine Entschuldigung. Finde ich nicht gut. Bin ich entsetzt.
Die Welt ist ungerecht und schlecht. Mal gucken, in Paradise Papers ist ja auch Apple erwähnt worden, nämlich auch sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt. Ähm aber das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr in dieser Folge. Denn wir sind Overtime.
Nee. Wir haben jetzt lange genug. Wir sind Overtime. Rufen sie jetzt an, die Leitungen sind geschaltet.
Nochmal die Nummer.
Null drei null einhundertzwanzig achtundachtzig drei achtundachtzig. Und die Frage, die wir euch stellen, lautet.
Was findet ihr eigentlich scheiße an Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Wir freuen uns auf eure Antworten und entlassen euch mit einem freundlichen. Tschau, tschau.
Tschüss. Ciao, ciao.